finally
bill barr has done something trump
supporters have been screaming
demanding the doj do something about all
of this evidence of voter fraud that's
been emerging
especially evidence like from the voter
integrity project which shows
well widespread voter fraud i wouldn't
say it definitively proves it but it
certainly raises a bunch of really
interesting questions well the good news
for all of you who have been waiting for
this billbar says
there's no evidence of fraud that would
have changed the outcome of the election
but wait what does that really mean
no evidence of fraud that would have
changed the outcome of the election
he basically said there's evidence of
fraud you see
over time it started with the media
saying there's no evidence of fraud
no evidence of widespread fraud then
unproven claims of fraud and now
unproven conspiracies because over time
we're getting more and more evidence
it's actually coming from some fairly
prominent people i'm not saying
that means donald trump lost because of
fraud in fact if bill barr comes out and
says he's reviewed this and doesn't see
the evidence
maybe bill barr is just right or maybe
bill barr is secretly working for the
deep state i don't know but we'll read
the story we'll figure out what's going
on
but we also have other news involving
bill barr he appointed
uh durham to be special counsel meaning
he's not going anywhere
we've got a bunch of other stories we're
going to talk about pertaining to you
know we have project veritas
putting out the cnn audio it's really
interesting we got the story about
elliot page
and the public uh transition announcing
that uh he is now trans we'll talk about
that stuff too
and uh of course we got you know ian
crossland hello everyone hi
thank you yes of course lydia is
producing i am over here in the corner
and uh joining uh joining us today is
ben dominic yes good to be with you i'm
happy to be here
so real quick who are you i'm the
publisher of the federalist
uh and uh i write uh the a daily
newsletter called the transom which
uh people can find obviously at the
federalist.com and thetransom.com
and i uh host primarily our our podcast
the federalist radio hour though i've
been
a little bit off lately because we had
our first kid so oh wow congratulations
thank you
cool thank you well then how about we
talk about some news if you haven't
already smash the subscribe button the
like button the notification bell we are
live on
friday at 8 pm and we're also on all
podcast platforms so subscribe if you
want to catch the show
later but uh the first story check us
out from the ap
disputing trump barr says no widespread
election fraud but i'm not gonna
i'm not gonna waste words with their
opinion i'll give you his act quote
barr told the ap that u.s attorneys and
fbi agents have been working to follow
up specific complaints and information
they've received but quote
to date we have not seen fraud on a
scale
that could have affected a different
outcome in the election the comments
which drew immediate criticism from
trump attorneys
were especially notable coming from barr
who has been one of the president's most
ardent allies
before the election he had repeatedly
raised the notion that male in voting
could be especially vulnerable to fraud
during the coronavirus pandemic
as americans feared going to polls and
instead chose to vote by mail
more to trump's liking barr revealed in
an ap interview that in october he had
appointed u.s attorney john durham as a
special counsel
giving the prosecutor the authority to
continue to investigate the origins of
the trump russia probe
after biden takes over and making it
difficult to fire him
biden hasn't said what he might do with
the investigation
but trent but his transition team didn't
comment on tuesday so let's
let's just start talking about what's
going on with you know bill barr
statements
i don't know if you've been following a
lot of the voter fraud stuff ben i have
absolutely well first let me just then
just what are your thoughts on the whole
thing
well i think that the big problem here
is that we have a system that really is
not designed
to be able to quickly prove
voter fraud on the scale that may have
happened in this case the doj is really
built to
make cases to investigate situations to
bring a case eventually to court
that can take years and i think that the
real problem is that we're discovering
that in a situation like this one where
they rushed
all of these changes many of which i
think may turn out in the
uh eventually to be considered
unconstitutional on the state level as
uh your guest sean parnell was bringing
up oh yeah the other day yeah he's the
plaintiff
yes exactly um which i think is a very
serious question
the real problem is what if the fraud is
hiding in plain sight
and i know that during the russia hoax
you would always hear that from you know
adam schiff and people like that oh you
know the collusion's higher
it's hiding in plain sight you know it's
right there it's right in front of you
what if instead the actual fraud is
something as basic as
mark zuckerberg spending hundreds of
millions of dollars to have
voter boxes put all over the united
states in ways that
may turn out to be targeted to specific
areas in you know
things that could turn out to be in-kind
contributions to democrats as opposed to
non-profits or
uh wisconsin they were doing democracy
in the park events yes
bringing people out telling them to vote
telling them who to vote for things like
that and it's it's a situation where i
mean you know our own reporter
john davidson who uh you know does a lot
of this stuff on the ground for us has
been detailing
the situations in native american
communities
where you literally had illegal raffles
and things like that going on to
incentivize people to vote
which is stuff that you know it's just
basic law like you can't pay someone to
vote or not vote you know it's and
and to me all of that adds up to a
situation where
there really is rampant you know fraud
weirdness lots of questions but i don't
think we have the capacity
in the doj to turn something around that
quickly in a way that would satisfy
americans
and that to me is is that's a big
unanswered question
that's it i completely agree and i
mentioned that's one of the biggest
problems we have is what we get two
weeks
to do this full-scale nationwide
investigation of 150 million votes
that's impossible yeah but we have more
and more evidence stacking up
now to clarify what bar has said they're
saying he's saying no evidence of
widespread fraud in fact i've titled
this stream no evidence of widespread
fraud what he said was to date
we have not seen fraud on a scale that
could have affected a different outcome
in the election
we can break that down it could mean
several things he could be saying as of
right now
we have seen fraud we haven't seen
enough does it mean he's done
investigating
no it doesn't but of course the headline
from every mainstream outlet is going to
be
no evidence of widespread fraud i i
default in that direction as well
but it's really hard to like cram a
title in you know on youtube so i have
to do
i do what i can i'm basing off the
article it could theoretically mean
we've seen fraud we haven't seen enough
yet
he did say to date right well i think
i'm thinking about james clapper i just
keep
thinking about james clapper testifying
to congress that they did not yeah
we did not wittingly spy on the american
people when they did wittingly spy
and under oath perjury to congress
and no no repercussions no none no so it
makes me think
they're all capable of lying well of
course they are i mean john brennan is
someone who
didn't just spy on the american people
he spied on congress
but but no just just for people who
don't be full of it i don't know let's
bill barr is the attorney general yeah
and then uh
clapper was he was a former cia former
msa
nsa and brennan and cia yes okay there
we go just want to make sure but
continue
but so the thing that i think we need to
keep in mind here is
effectively what bar is saying is he
can't answer that question
he doesn't actually have the capability
to find that in such a short amount of
time
at the same time i think that he is
really engaged here in a bit of
setting expectations which is we all
know that this
mail-in balloting thing was something
that a lot of folks mostly on the left
have been pushing for for a long time
it's not going away
they're going to keep it in the in the
midterms they're going to try to keep it
for the next presidential
and to me at a certain point the
attitude of people
who want to see the trump agenda
furthered who supported him this time
around who are furious at this result
has to be we can't let this happen again
because otherwise it will and it's in
the incentives of a lot of these
politicians to make sure that it does
so that they don't have some reversal of
fortune in the midterms as they all
expect they will so this is the most
important thing coming out of all of
this
if maybe trump doesn't win
right i know the trump supporters are
saying we're going to win we got to
fight oh you know look i i've been
saying over and over again that in my
opinion it was always extremely likely
once they called it for biden it's going
to be biden but trump
should keep fighting no matter what
because we have seen historic anomalies
this like the georgio they found all
these votes
and there's a possibility trump could
figure out a legal path to victory
through legal challenges
and through the electoral college but
outside of all of that let's say the
worst case scenario
for the trump supporters is that it's
done trump loses joe biden's president
this fight that trump has led will push
us towards more secure voting
at the very least and it could also mean
no mail in voting
the fight coming from people like mike
kelly i think mike kelly's name and sean
parnell
could result in more secure elections no
universal mail in voting
and i hear from all these leftists and
democrats saying but universal mail and
voting is so easy and so popular even
republicans love it and i'm like yes it
is easy i completely agree
and easy doesn't mean secure in fact the
more you
remove security the easier things get
but then
the more likely you're going to see
fraud or impropriety and we want secure
elections
we want to be able to audit them
properly we want observers i think
at the very end of this the worst case
scenario is
we're going to have grounds based on the
things they find or have already found
to say no to a lot of this no excuse
mail-in voting and demand more secure
elections and things like voter id for
instance
i i think that that is uh that's a
hopeful uh image and i hope that that
is something that comes forward because
i'm concerned about the trust level
that's going to exist among
the american people we've seen the total
degradation of faith
in every institution of american life
basically
people trust the military and small
business and that's it if you look at
all the polls
and so at the end of the day this is
going to be one more aspect that people
have a lack of trust for given the
closeness of proximity of the electoral
college and
the fact that we're probably going to
see something like this play out again
in two years or four years and it
without
major changes you know what's really
crazy about the whole thing though is
that
if so the pennsylvania state legislature
said we don't have enough time to pass a
joint resolution calling the election in
dispute
they could have that's freaky to me that
we could have a
whole federal election let's look at
this way let's say
2024 i can't imagine joe biden running
for reelection
i just i don't see it so maybe it's you
know kamala harris now she's going to
run for president
you know going from vice president to
president or whatever i'm saying
hypothetically she's running against i
don't know who
who do you think would run in 2024 for
the republican a lot of people will but
let's let's just say for the argument
just because he's known and a known
commodity kanye west ted cruz
let's just say ted cruz because he came
in second effectively last time all
right so we got ted cruz
kamala harris comes down the electoral
college ted cruz is up
he's projected to win and then a swing
state with
a democratic legislature says we're
going to appoint
our electors we're going to dispute it
yeah pulling his you know his votes away
or something like that
that that could happen now and that to
me is kind of nuts that
trump needed three states he needs three
states it can still happen
to effectively challenge the uh the
result of the election
it it might actually happen i mean we
just had this hearing in what was it
michigan today
where it was this is the first time i
think of these hearings they've done
it was actually in a state house it was
actually in an official building
they were doing these hotels before
right so they had the first ev
evidentiary hearing with the republican
state legislature in uh pennsylvania i
think it was right in gettysburg
right and when i questioned why they're
doing in a hotel a ton of people were
saying oh it's gettysburg it's the
second you know gettysburg address or
whatever
and i'm just like i don't know i kind of
feel like they're just you know
placating people you're like oh yeah
we're gonna do a hearing it's gonna be a
hotel
when they did it in arizona to hyatt i
said that makes no sense okay there's no
there's no the hyatt speech there's no
you know the phoenix address or whatever
but now they're in michigan they
actually had a legit hearing and there
was some
i mean it's the stories that are coming
out of this stuff are insane
people saying they're being harassed
chased out they're not allowed to
observe at all in all these places
weird stories about trucks pulling up in
the middle of the night you know pulling
out boxes of ballots and things like
that claiming
we're not counting but then they add
vote counts later on clearly something
weird's going on
and that's that's not even the the half
of it and and what i really want to say
to
everybody who you know has been arguing
with their friends
about you know fraud in this election
where people might be citing
cnn to them saying oh there is no fraud
there's fraud in every american election
it always happens and it's typically on
a low level
and very pedestrian in nature it's
literally a box that appears or
disappears
you know it's something that it doesn't
take a convoluted machine
to make it work i mean the machine that
ran in
new orleans all the way up until katrina
was totally like that it was organic
everyone knew what they had to do it
didn't require any kind of coordination
or meetings
katrina smashes that whole population it
spreads out and suddenly republicans
start winning elections
and that's something that i think you
know speaks to the organic built into
the
society nature of these things of a
place like philly
and again i still think this is a
situation where
this was effectively lost for donald
trump
when republican lawyers didn't get their
act together
ahead of time months ago and start
fighting and disputing
these things more effectively within
these different systems they were
getting shut down by the courts but they
needed to put more effort into it
because i think that the the moment that
those rules were locked in
they were facing a circumstance where if
he lost the state it would be almost
impossible
to prove enough right you know what i've
been saying i said trump got oceans 11.
that the real heist happened months ago
in october
of 2019 in in pennsylvania the
republicans passed act 77
which other republicans are now suing
calling it unconstitutional
why did they pass no excuse mail-in
voting before covet happened
they knew mail-in voting was always
their path
to essentially cheating the election and
the reason i say cheating is that
changing the rules the 11th hour to
benefit one side because you know it's
what you need is
it's cheating yeah so it what it they
they say covet is the excuse when
i talk about people say well people were
scared of code they needed an option no
no because they were already passing
these bills
you know in other places and then when
you talk about the the anomalies
for instance they say and i'm kind of
sidetracking here
they say the anomalies are easily
explained because the republic you know
the republicans stopped them from
counting ballots until election night
which was not true for some states
there's just those weird anomalous
spikes but anyway going back to the
oceans getting oceans 11 they pass all
of these rule changes
where i had been making video after
video saying
this is that how they're going to how
they're going to how they're going to
cheat
republicans are going to show up on
election day like they normally do
and they're going to follow the rules
and democrats have every opportunity now
to hold democracy in the park events to
do
you know what raffles you were
mentioning illegal raffles there's
accusations of of ballot harvesting now
we've got minnesota
and in what was the other one texas
where where the veritas
yeah i believe i haven't been able to
follow veritas has been putting out so
many things that i'm a little behind by
veritas consumption i have to admit
but congrats to them yeah yeah so that
we we have
you know these videos showing people are
doing about harvesting we had on
jeremy from the quartering and he said
that at his house
like democrats showed up and we're like
have you voted do you have your absentee
ballots
and they received them but he never
requested one so
there's a lot of weird things there but
there's i think i think one of the
simple things is
maybe this is fraud maybe they were
requesting bouts for people and then
showing up and telling them to vote
or maybe they gave themselves a month
plus
to go to go around telling people did
you vote yet did you vote
why don't you vote did you vote we saw
in one of the videos from veritas a
woman saying she was like hey come out
and have free drinks with me
did you vote and so they're like okay
fine they fill it out there you go here
take my vote now give me the beer
yeah that kind of ballot harvesting that
was the trick because guess what that's
a real vote yes
now there is freaky stuff like matt
brainard for the voter integrity project
says here's 20 plus thousand people who
changed their addresses and then voted
twice
that's like okay we kind of got evidence
of widespread fraud going on
maybe maybe it wasn't enough to change
the results or maybe you know bill barr
looked at it
and then said uh this is not legit
i don't know yeah i think that that's
impossible to know and i think we'll be
pouring over this for a long time but i
do think that
we're now in territory where one side
definitely thinks that they got jobbed
and the other side definitely thinks
that they won but they have the sour
taste in their mouth because of how
unwilling the other side is to accept it
and because of the performance of
republicans generally
uh so that sets up a a very
strife-filled political scenario
where joe biden is absolutely not going
to unify anybody
no it's going to be joe biden is the
worst possible thing to have happened to
this country
especially right now but i'll tell you
first and foremost i'm sorry if if i
can't believe joe biden won fair and
square you know why
trump wins the republicans win down
ballot they reclaim
many house seats they lost none they
gained many they didn't take the
majority
they defended the senate they won every
state a state house
or state race so it looked like trump
was on the ticket
then joe biden who doesn't didn't
campaign i mean he literally campaigned
but you know what i mean like
come on he's in the basement at the time
he's calling lids every day
he was not having big events or any
rallies somehow beat barack obama's 2008
ground-shattering you know 69 million
votes
joe biden didn't campaign and beat trump
the argument i hear is
people hate trump that much that they
voted against him i don't i don't think
so
biden also i mean they also outspent him
uh and out manipulated uh him in ways
that we can't
leave out of this the in-kind donation
from big tech
oh absolutely absolutely i mean i don't
even know how you could estimate it
um the amount of money that they spent
obviously they spent almost twice as
much money just from the campaign
organizations et cetera
yeah and so i think this is a situation
where
money did talk this time around and also
that the
the warping influence that we've had on
narrative
from an entire corporate democrat media
establishment
designed to take down trump focused on
you know telling the entire country that
he's this racist horrible
person who has to be destroyed for the
sake of humanity
for year upon year upon year and they
end up with a situation where you know
he wins
more votes than barack obama actually
did and and you know wins
uh you know more votes than any you know
any republican and it's it's this i know
i mean it's kind of amazing i know too
many democrats who switched parties
it you know coming out of chicago there
are people i've known my whole life who
have always been democrat kind of
passively
now hardcore trump supporters and so i
see things like that
that's obviously anecdotal doesn't mean
you know that's that's my personal
friend and family bubble
but i i look at uh the new york times
reporting i look at moody's analytics
all of these things in indicating a
trump victory nothing indicating a trump
defeat
albeit when kovitt hit it shifted a lot
of the economic forecasts
but it's still crazy to see all the
polls were wrong off by like
seven percent four to seven no no i i
want to stop you there because i think
we keep saying the polls were wrong
the pollsters lied some polls were wrong
some polls were propaganda
right right okay we have to keep in mind
like media polls are frequently
they are propaganda or they are intended
to be the basis for a story a narrative
and and you can't think about them the
same the reason that the
actual like pole people are are are
upset or that are
are concerned about the future of their
industry is that the
the behind the scenes polls were also
wrong right like the the ones that are
given to
corporate and lobbying clients etc about
i mean i had all of these people coming
to me saying
there is no chance susan collins is
going to win you got to stop saying that
you know like like i just kept saying
you know what i just i think she knows
how to win maine
and then and and they're saying you know
look we have we got our internals
you know she's not going to be on this
committee anymore we're talking to the
you know to the other side that kind of
thing
and then of course she wins easily so it
is it is a fact that pulls our
propaganda
and i know immediately there's going to
be mainstream journalists there's going
to be leftists being like ah conspiracy
theories no no hold on
there there are many polls that are
legit there are many polls that are
overt propaganda and they function as
such ian let me ask you a question
okay would you be in favor of taking
some tax money and invest
and using that to invest in new
technologies that could improve american
energy independence
well that's a vague question tim would i
thought that was very specific
would you be in favor of allocating some
of the us how much is some
first off it's just your opinion some it
could be anything i'm just asking if you
think
i'm not gonna drag you here yeah i would
it sounds great doesn't it sounds
awesome okay let me mark you down for
favors green new deal okay
now let me ask you a question would you
be in favor of a policy that
dramatically overhauls the entire
medical industry
and bans private insurance
uh no oh opposes green new deal yeah you
see you can ask questions
and what they'll do then is they'll say
they'll they'll show a thing saying
support it'll say green new deal support
oppose
and they won't tell you what they're
asking those are the propaganda polls
there are polls that will show you the
methodology they'll show the questions
they ask and that's you have to do when
you go and try and figure out what
they're really talking about well the
biggest thing that has been plaguing the
polling industry and i don't want to get
so off tangent on bar but um
so someone who you should actually have
on the program emily eakins who's the
head of
polling at the cato institute
and previously at the reason foundation
has done phenomenal research over the
past several years about the difficulty
uh she was the one who was the source of
that pull that so many people cite
about the unwillingness of people to
share their true views
right and kind of seeking out the shy
trump voter or the shy
conservative voter in lots of different
respects and it's
very difficult to do it you almost have
to one of the polls not
from something she commissioned but one
that i saw from this cycle
behind the scenes had this hilarious
question in it i think i can share it
now that uh you know it's
well in the past but it was do you know
someone
who you believe supports president trump
but would be unwilling
to say that publicly for fear of the
reaction okay and so they have this
percentage that's like this is how many
it's a huge number you know say and then
the follow-up question to those who said
yes is
does that previous question describe you
and a lot of them say yes like it's a
huge portion of themselves
it's because they've been prepped for it
right otherwise it's like some strange
person calls me and they ask me whether
i support this guy everybody says it's
racist i'm not gonna say yes but but
also because the way the question is
framed
it could have repercussions on them yes
so it's basically it sounds like they're
coming at you as someone who's
sympathetic
to that you know having an impact on you
but yeah you know
what i was saying i i i love it they
they they
they put out this clip of me saying 49
state landslide over and over and over
again
because i was for one saying here's the
hypotheticals
like for instance there's a lot of
videos where i'd say something like look
if trump
pardoned all non-violent drug offenders
and and and issued an executive order
legalizing pot the federal level
49 landslide and so i'm not literally
predicting this i'm saying
if trump does something crazy this is
what happened which is the one state he
would lose in that scenario what's the
one state yeah he would lose in that
scenario i don't know
49 oregon yeah
you know the point to it was basically
there's hypotheticals i kind of lost my
train of thought on
why i was busy why i was bringing that
up but you know back to
polls i guess was the general the i
don't want to
you know stay too long on polls but
because i know you there's so many other
news things to talk about but the one
thing that i do want people to keep in
mind is
they were broken last time around oh the
secretary
the vast majority did not fix it and in
the handful of places that got it right
last time around
and worked to fix it okay including
trafalgar and other places like that
just got
bashed over and over by both pollsters
and like the pole bros
the people who just analyzed poles for a
living who write for a lot of these
media sites and at the end of the day
they ended up being
a ton more accurate even as they were
being criticized over and over again
and one of the big aspects of this that
i think kept getting cited by these pole
bros was
well you're not looking at the granular
you know precinct level data the way
that we are like we have
we have the true cross you know here you
know and you don't really know what it's
what is in it um and that was where they
had some of the biggest misses
it's why they got so many of these house
races wrong the the cook report
for instance uh not to single them out
because so many people were wrong but
dave wasserman
there literally had a tweet up where he
said i wish that i could erase
everything that i've written
in 2020 about the outcome in the house
and revert to what i said
in december 2019 or whatever when i said
republicans would pick up five so i i i
remember my train of thought it was that
the one thing i predicted pretty much
spot on as many did was the polls would
be wrong
and one of the reason i gave is you have
all these people who lie about you all
the time
they accuse you of being a bigot and a
racist and all these things
the media is constantly full of
falsehoods and then when you get a phone
call
you know hi i'm with you know abc
washington post poll
do you support donald trump no no not me
i never let any of them over for
thanksgiving i mean i guess
i guess i can't any of them though for
anyway you you see how the media treated
that guy you know i
remember that guy who posted the the
video of nancy pelosi slowed down
and they were like they show his pic his
picture his name where he works
you had the the guy who made the meme of
trump body slamming the cnn guy
and they're like we will publish his
name if he ever does this again
so when the media calls you and says hi
friend
do you support donald trump we're the
media you can trust us
and and keep in mind did you see the any
of the
most recent tech hearing the holly uh
a little bit it's just it's just circled
so yeah so the most interesting
there were two interesting things from
that interaction one was zuckerberg
saying that he didn't know whether they
tracked every time an employee had
looked at
uh someone's facebook messages secretly
he said that and secondly secondly the
admission that
um they actually have a program
that zuckerberg sort of initially said
he didn't recognize the name but then it
became clear that he kind of knew what
holly was talking about
that they haven't owned their own
internal program that is designed to
share information across big tech
about the activities of people on other
platforms
in order to inform their way that
facebook treats them
in other words that like tracking
someone's youtube comments
right and then using them in other words
you think you think you're working
separately and that you're communicating
separately
but if everything is just going into a
dump of
this person needs to be downgraded
silence
i mean that's wow and on the the uber
shadow profile that reminds me of what
happened to sargon
where he said some naughty word on yeah
yeah
you're familiar with sargon i'm familiar
with this but yes what what was uh
remind me he just
banned from patreon yes so if those are
familiar patreon is like a you know
people can sign up to give you a certain
amount of money and then you release
content over a certain period of time
sargon aka carl benjamin he's a youtuber
he has he's a podcast
uh new one called the lotus eaters shout
out shouted him out before um
he did a live stream with a very very
tiny live stream only a few thousand
people
and he called them white i think he
called them like uh
something like white n-word or whatever
and he was making a point that
the things you do to describe other
people is how you actually are so you're
describing yourself
it was an obscure two-hour stream right
in the middle where he said this
and patreon found it apparently someone
submitted it to patreon and said look at
this and they went okay
nuked his nuked his account all of his
income well not always but
his income from patreon just gone so
they said
yes we take off you know offline
behavior into account how you act on
other platforms
which was really i think people don't
understand that that's where we're
headed
yeah like that is absolutely where we
are headed and it's not going to be
people
always try to scare you about some
situation where government does these
things
it's not that it's not going to be that
it's it's corporate america it's the
people who sound like a liberal
well it seems how they used to sound
well how they used to sound exactly look
this is this is a very real thing that
is a transition that is happening and
that
the i would say more the kamala harris
wing of the democratic party once
which is to say we are going to use
corporate america to weaponize or to
administrate our woke program even as we
you know we put it out through taxpayer
funds in in the public schools etc
but corporate america doesn't want to
fight this stuff they're happy as long
as they make money right right and so
they're happy with you know
an america last foreign policy where
where china
is just this wonderful trading partner
and taking away all of these american
jobs and making all sorts of
cheap crap that we can sell to people um
here in america
and uh and you know everybody should be
happy all the big tech companies they've
been profiting so much from this past
year
they're only going to continue and
meanwhile small business america gets
absolutely crushed cnbc reporting
this week that they're uh that their
optimism has only gone down since biden
was
was elected and that i think is going to
continue to be the dynamic here and you
have these major corporations that are
come
that are going to come and effectively
crush you through
a thousand sort of little things that
you can't use anymore you can't be on
this platform you can't do
and then and then it becomes you can't
be a part of our you know
hotel rewards program you know you can't
fly on our airline
oh yeah some people i mean you look you
look at your city no you're looking at
uh enrique tario
they have so much power to cut you off
yeah completely your water is cut off
i mean they can do garcetti yeah
garcetti and allie said he was gonna cut
your water off if you had people over
somehow they didn't do that when hunter
biden went to that house and partied
with death
we have a first amendment right to
peaceably assemble the constitution
doesn't say for what
if i want to peaceably assemble to
discuss episodes of spongebob
squarepants so be it
so if i have a party and i'm in la the
constitution guarantees me that right he
says i'm gonna shut your water off
that is a human rights violation and it
literally is
i mean i can't even imagine what that
would do to you know someone who had
health needs who
you know turning off their power and
their diabetic yeah i mean yes no more
refrigerator no more insulin
oxygen this is this is how how
absolutely insane things are getting
what people don't realize
about this kind of like dystopian
nightmare
you've got all these people that are
effectively in the matrix
going along with all of this and that's
that's
freaky so you think we're going social
credit score total
you're watering your electricity joe
biden as part of his pack with bernie
sanders
has a plan for a publix uh credit
scoring agency based off of your
privilege criteria something like that
it means that if you're a straight white
male you get a negative score
i'm not kidding you so this was written
about there's an organization that works
with um
like this i forgot what's called it's a
credit you know like
they write about their write reports on
different credit agencies and it's like
an internal
corporate thing i did a segment on this
they said we don't know how biden
would even implement this because it's a
violation of the law it's violation of
civil rights law
to create a public scoring agency that
gives you credit based on your
like you know privileged criteria or
something like that so is what they've
they've talked about it this kind of
reminds me of but hold on so
when you when you when you see something
like that and then you look at what they
tried in california with
with prop 16 repeal it was yeah repeal
prop 209 which was their civil rights
provision in the constitution it failed
it starts in california it comes to the
rest of the country
if the critical race theorists have
their way they will absolutely
repeal the civil rights act of 19. so
they want to put like a star of david on
my chest because i'm a white guy
no no no no no no no a little piece of
flair no no no give me a little red
insignia on my chest
no you're gonna you're gonna go to work
you're gonna go to a bank and you're
gonna say i'd like to buy a house and
they're gonna say
well your public credit score is 470
because you're a straight line we
deserve most of our loans for ethnic
minorities i'm sorry you're not welcome
look i mean ibra mex kennedy you know
the whole passage in his book is about
how
you know capitalism is racism and racism
is capitalism
and those things are like totally united
together and so to me
this is a this is a situation where this
new administration wants to buy off
the the woke progressives with
these various aspects of policy even as
they refuse to do anything that people
who actually
care about class divides in america and
about
uh the economy that's moved you know
really up into the last couple of years
in a really negative direction
in this sense not addressing any of
those things just pretending that it
doesn't exist and trying to satisfy it
with
diversity quotas and the like let's uh
let's let's how about we go for the
dangerous conversation the one that's
going to get us banned
trying to be as careful as possible
drugs juno star
eliot page announces he is transgender
so this is something that uh came out
earlier look i'm i'm fairly libertarian
so if somebody
you know is trans or whatever and they
want to be called whatever i i have
absolutely no problem and more power to
them they can live their life be happy
and do all that stuff
but uh when you're talking about you
know the democrats and
and take going after this woke you know
giving them the woke things they want
talking about social media censorship
and stuff like this we're in we're in
dangerous territory
talking about these issues i'll just
i'll come out right come right out and
say it
there was a website um dedicated to
stories about de-transitioning
from people who came out as trans got
you know uh
it's it's look it's all part of the woke
you know critical gender theory stuff
and there are people telling their story
saying they were pressured into it
pressured into life-altering surgeries
or taking medications
and all of these posts get banned from
reddit
these forums where people are talking
about are banned from reddit
conversations like the one we're having
now like i said it's dangerous because
they could ban me for it
and that's crazy because if the internet
only allows if these big tech companies
only allow conversation that's
it's good it's good it's always good no
matter what then all
anyone will ever hear is how good it is
and they won't hear that look in life
sometimes things aren't good
and i'm not saying what you know elliot
page is doing is not is good or bad i'm
just saying
you need to have a balanced and healthy
view analyzing all of these you know
different subjects
and what people are saying in one way or
another but when we start to have
the mass censorship uh on social media
conversations that can't happen can't
talk about covet in a certain way
they'll ban you in two seconds can't
talk about masks can't report on studies
about masks they'll ban you
then what ends up happening is you
develop a society that has a skewed and
warped view on many different subjects
so now we we're we're ending up with and
i'm not trying to direct
any uh you know uh i or anything towards
elliot page
for those those aren't familiar it's it
i might get banned for this because it's
called dead naming but elliott page
formerly ellen page no joke it's it's
it's like that
that difficult to talk about this stuff
without because youtube will come down
and they'll and they'll nuke you
immediately so i uh had a personal uh
interaction actually multiple personal
interactions with
um with mr page uh
on several occasions because
we were for a while neighbors really
yeah lived
very close to each other and
at times in fact i think twice
i conversed with and bought drinks for
uh mr page without even knowing it so i
i think that now
i should be at least earn allyship for
that because i had no idea how
progressive i was being in the moment
but in retrospect i was being very very
reaching out we actually talked about
mike pence at the time yes
but uh wonderful wonderful actor
and uh i'm sure that you know there are
a lot of trans roles
now that you know people say trans
people should be
the only people who are allowed to play
them obviously that's something that
scarlett johansson ran into a couple of
years ago
had to drop a roll and cancel the entire
movie yeah so definitely going to be i
think uh some productive opportunities
for
uh mr page i think elliott is an amazing
human
um regardless of sex or gender or
whatever and i think that it's important
that we can talk about
sex and gender and like he and she and
him and them and they and all that
crap like it you know like normal
like we have to talk about that yeah you
have to have you have to be able to have
conversations about this stuff yeah well
but that's impossible in a situation
where government comes in
or corporate america comes in and
basically says you
you have to be walking on eggshells
because you use
you might use the wrong pronoun and
especially when you have this fiction
this idea that the internet has embraced
that suddenly as soon as someone makes
that change
in their life there's a refusal of any
kind of admission
that this change happened and to me it's
it's not like
i don't know i i just think that this is
a situation where you you have to be
able to talk about it openly without
fear of repercussions
as you see in places like canada well so
there there's uh a big part of the story
which um
what we i think we can do yes we have is
that in the uk there's a ruling that
effect
that essentially says under 16s can't
get puberty blockers so
you need you need to have these
conversations because it's not
like i think leftists don't realize this
maybe because they're too young but
think about pot legalization which is
happening across the country
the only reason it's happening is
because people were smoking it illegally
and they knew they liked it and the
conversation started happening around
legalizing it which means a bunch of
criminals were getting together
committing crimes
and decided hey it shouldn't be a crime
anymore and then a bunch of states were
like
that's actually a good point we
shouldn't be if everybody said you can't
do it you'll go to jail you'll be banned
your life will be ruined
we would never have it so that means you
have to have
calm rational reasonable converse
reasonable conversations but i'll bring
up a couple points
that i think are a a serious problem for
us in society based on the things we're
seeing with elliott page and again
not directing any duration at elliott
specifically but
wikipedia for instance is is is
widely used one of the most popular
sites in the world has very serious
problems notably
you can't use twitter or social media of
an individual as a source
yet in every circumstance where an
individual comes out as trans the moment
they tweet
the wikipedia editors all change
everything as though that's a legitimate
source what if you were hacked
and someone tweeted something and they
change your wikipedia because of this
it also creates a very strange
circumstance uh somebody tweeted
something
where it said uh in reference to elliot
page in 2008 he
was named the 93rd sexiest woman alive
so it it's and i'm not saying again you
know i'm trying to be careful i'm not
trying to be mean or disrespectful
it creates very confusing circumstances
that people outside of the woke bubbles
will have no idea what's going on or
what this means so when you talk about
well real quick the reason i bring that
up is that if you go to somebody who's
maybe like you know
not super active on the internet which
is most people and you
you read them that line they would
assume it was a gag
they would be like oh like borat or
something right like if borat won an
award for being a sexy woman they
wouldn't realize
that you know elliot was previously
ellen that there's you know there's an
issue here
these things haven't been worked through
our society hasn't
had it i'll put i'll put it this way
these things have
have seemingly just blinked into
existence to the average person
we don't know what this means we don't
know how to interact but they're banning
us they're coming for our jobs they're
threatening our careers because of it
i would think like if you talked about
the past of someone that transitioned
that you would use the old
pronoun if you're talking about that
time when they used to be the old
pronouns
people can change their names all the
time and it doesn't confuse people
i guess that's it's kind of like
changing your name but but i just think
that people
living in this fictional world just
makes for all
the demands i think that it places on
people who are not
very online and i mean you know imagine
someone who tomorrow
you know picks up juno and says some
compliment about paige's performance
and then gets accused of you know dead
naming
and and you know not respecting etcetera
but this this
this will happen yeah so someone who's
not very online might tweet
just watch juno ellen page she was
fantastic and then they're going to get
attacked
they're going to get they're going to
get banned they're going to get
suspended on twitter
you i remember uh zooby remember zooby
first of all
zooby identifying as a woman and then
broke the deadlift record
to make a point but then tweeted someone
in on twitter okay dude
got suspended yeah and and because but
it was like an informal colloquial okay
dude
look they're coming for gina carano from
the mandalorian right because of putting
uh beep bop boop or whatever in here she
wouldn't put pronouns
in her twitter bio instead of the the
pronouns
were they they were forcing her to put
pronouns in no she was she was getting
yelled at for
not doing it that's that's like some c16
canadian jordan peterson speaking right
for compelled speech jordan peterson
warned us
but listen it's not the government doing
it it's private corporations oh you're
gonna make me cry just mentioning his
name
jordan
so much about the story was that they
thought that that was a story they
needed to tell
to the reporter like this is going to
help us it's going to
show how passionate so i heard they were
going to publish a jordan peterson book
and i cried and it's like
my question is what was the book about i
don't know he's always right or
something
cooking jordan peterson family recipes
and it's nothing but steak yes just take
every page
i love this idea that's a great idea i
was thinking about sex and gender about
how okay when i was raised i was taught
that sex and gender are different
sex is your bio biology and gender is
what you identify with the most
well gender is is uh social social
security
is how you socially identify no no no
like words can have gender
so in romance languages words are
gendered so
why not just acknowledge whatever sex
you are
okay but then if you want to change your
gender just go legally do it at a
at the courthouse no no no no why not
that would be so easy no no no no no
i'm sorry your id doesn't say man or
woman it says male or female and the
reason for that is typically medical or
for leak important legal reasons and
that's it you could add something to the
identification if you wanted to use a
different gender this is
this is the issue that's really causing
everything to kind of break down is that
you're correct
uh sex and gender are different things
typically for the longest time
especially with me growing up people use
sex and gender interchangeably right
but uh if someone comes out and says
it's a distinction i can say absolutely
fine no problem
the issue is though on your passport on
your id on your birth certificate it
says male or female not
to make you feel better not to express
your identity but to explain to people
medically what you likely are it's not
perfect
but i i we i did a segment on this for
for scanner which is the news outlet now
emily and rocco are running we talked
with dr deborah so
and we she's wonderful she's wonderful
she's a she's brilliant
and in it we talk about the 1992 i
believe health revitalization act
before this 1992 get this not even that
long ago when they did clinical trials
they had no obligation to actually
do clinical trials on both males and
females and so what ended up happening
was
medication would come out that would be
particularly ineffective or dangerous
for females when you do when there's
when there's a medical emergency there's
a reason why
there's a male or female on your id it's
not just so that when you show your id
someone can see this and then call you
by your proper pronouns
it's so that if you fall down and
they're like what medication can we give
this person
they have a better idea now in most
circumstances most times someone's in a
medical emergency male or female they're
going to be able to help you out just
fine
but there are circumstances where for
distinct reasons
it's important that we understand your
biology is not you can have like
it's a male she her like if you wanted
to go to the courthouse and get your
gender legally changed
but still have that it says male so if
there's a medicine that it's dangerous
for him
i just think that a lot of this gets
into the nitty-gritty of the way that
that
uh you know government and corporations
have to define
everything about us at all times and
it's just it's it's a very difficult
thing but
just to go back to the original point
you made the the page story
um and again as as an actor
great uh uh umbrella academy was good
you know the
great next man uh yeah and incredible um
and i just think that
part of the problem is you you put these
two stories next to each other the uk
story
and the and the uh page story and then
this other
piece that got written this past week uh
perhaps i
i don't know how she knew this story was
coming by uh katie herzog
from uh who does blocked and reported
with jesse single
the podcast which you should listen to
she wrote this piece this amazing piece
about
uh called uh where where are all the
lesbians gone
uh that talked about the fact early on
that they're like only 15 lesbian bars
left in america
and that all these people are redefining
themselves as trans
instead of lesbian it's it that's crazy
look at this
uh katie writes lesbian bars have always
been vastly outnumbered by bars for
straight people and gay men
but but in the 1980s there were more
than 200 lesbian bars in the u.s
what happened well a lot of them sucked
the first lesbian bars i went to in my
early 20s were dank smokey caves where
women in khaki shorts and backward caps
grinded on each other to outcast
they could have been fret bars if not
for the notable absence of men uh and
she
i don't know if she specifically
references uh 15 or whatever she says
there's also economic challenge
this is what took down lexington and
infamous i can't use that word
unfortunately on youtube
um but yeah she goes on to say there
used to be a lot more and that was kind
of the point i want to
bring up she the the point that she's
overall making is that something is
happening here
in society and the problem that you're
pointing out is that
basically if we move into the way that
certain people want us to talk about
this
we can't even discuss it we can't even
you know kind of put it out on the table
and say well let's talk about this
interesting phenomenon what's happening
why is it happening and to me that's
just it's just so
we got to talk to you she she literally
opens with oop let's click the wrong
thing
she literally was just with opens with
there are only 15 lesbian bars left in
the entire country
it's crazy so they're familiar with get
the l out
this was a protest in the i believe in
the in the uk
many of these uh lesbians are being
called you know turfs
they were basically saying that trans
activism is erasing
lesbians and this is kind of what i
guess katie herzog is saying about the
lesbian bars
i just think that this is a situation
where it's almost impossible to discuss
all of these things honestly if we have
the kind of restrictions
that are trying to be put up it's crazy
and that's crazy especially with that uk
case that is going to lead to
a ton more lawsuits what was the case oh
yeah so high court ruling on puberty
blockers protects teenagers
says women who sued nhs three judges say
children
under 16 must be able to give their
competent consent and understand the
treatment
so this was a a a woman who transitioned
and then realized it was for them a
mistake and then de-transition
de-transitioned
but i tell you you can't have that
conversation there like i mentioned
there was a website
that told all these stories i'll tell
you man some of the most horrifying
stories and
the reason why they were horrifying is
that they were saying their loved ones
were just telling them
do it do all of these things and they
weren't getting an honest
healthy therapeutic and and loving
analysis of what was going on in their
lives and what they really needed to
feel better they were kids
it was it was the stories of all types
stories of all types and uh
there were there were forums on reddit
that talked about this they like read it
you know subreddits where they were like
here's here's what what i went through
banned all banned and then mario lopez
comes along and says you shouldn't be
shoving drugs into kids
and suddenly has to go through mario
mario lopez said
three-year-olds probably don't know if
they're trans
and he had to apologize for it so who
he was gonna get fired i guess by who i
mean listen
mario you shouldn't have apologized
absolutely not
when i was three i probably wanted to be
a triceratops yeah
joe biden said if an eight-year-old
decides to be trans there should be no
discrimination
i used to play as wonder woman i used to
dress up not dress up but i would run
around be like i'm wonder woman she was
my favorite character so i
but i i didn't want to be a woman i
always was like what would it be like to
be a girl i mean it's just crazy i i
thoughts but
so so this is what happens joe biden
when he said that if an eight-year-old
chooses to be trans it should be no
discrimination
that is the kind of i believe that's
irresponsible i believe the correct
answer should be
the issues of private family matters for
minors is the responsibility of their
parents and their doctors mm-hmm
that's it yeah he shouldn't be telling
or encouraging or saying no no listen
there are certainly circumstances where
there are transgender uh kids and
teenagers and the parents need to make
sure they're doing everything right
and the doctors are doing everything
right he's so checked out when he did
that at the debate
and told that woman about her
eight-year-old yeah the town hall yes
yeah yeah but but but that again is the
sinkhole
that you just get sucked into on these
things where where logic goes out the
window and you don't think about the
ramifications of it
and then you wake up one morning and
there are a bunch of kids who need
therapy
and are pissed off at their parents for
shoving drugs into them for something
there was just a phase
there was that uh that viral clip from i
think that hbo show
where the the young trans kid telling
his mom my life is ruined
i hate this i shouldn't have ever done
it and the mom just stares
and says nothing and it's almost like
you know
it goes back into what i was saying
about censorship the fact that even
having this conversation we run the risk
of
getting demonetized and getting banned
but it needs to be talked about um
if this mother never heard any of these
conversations then the only
thing she knew was must be good now now
the kid is telling his mom and this is
on hbo this is going viral
my life is ruined i can't stand it
parents need to be there for their kids
man this is just i mean it's
it's a tragedy and the adults
who i think we will look back on this as
being a
very stupid and crazy time for the kind
of adults
who just egged all of this on and acted
as if there were no downsides
you know science can solve your problems
for you and make all the
confusion go away when kids are confused
and teenagers especially are confused
and we should let people work their way
through these things and make decisions
as
informed adults and not force them into
boxes early on
based on you know what you've read in
the in the silly magazines that make for
make arguments for dean vogue yes
and stuff like that and you know that
one of the issues is uh
i think there's a kind of a feedback
loop that is driving the left insane
so they make rules to appease what they
think is normal
then those rules create an environment
where you can only talk about what they
think is normal
which then slowly starts spinning and
spinning and moving further and further
left so
you end up with the ceo of twitter
saying here's our rules
and the rules are applicable or
understood only by eight percent of the
population the ultra progressives
regular people are being banned left and
right creating an echo chamber of all
this far left nonsense
which then results in people growing up
getting jobs at twitter and then
believing the insane nonsense and then
enacting rules
of what they think is normal and it's an
endless sentence and that's why the
future of the left
uh depends on the line that runs through
aoc's heart
because she as someone who is a
legitimate economic progressive
and a populist i believe on those points
had
has shunted those issues to the side in
order to
accept and embrace this woke
ridiculousness
and you know a byproduct of that she and
the rest of the squad pushing bernie
into that box which
he had never occupied before
historically he had you know talked
about
you know race as you being used by you
know corporations to divide us
in ways where that we should be united
based on class interests
and economic interests until 2016. until
yes and then he went wow and then and
then we have a situation where
you know the the left now are you just
going to be satisfied with the situation
where facebook is policing this stuff
and youtube is banning tim poole
and you know you have big tech doing all
these different things carrying out your
woke agenda meanwhile
you know the very class people you've
always said you were fighting for
against
the amazons of the world are getting
absolutely crushed
i mean that's that's a scary future
when the left is in favor of massive
private corporations
unconstrained power to silence and
disrupt the lives of the working class
do you think it's because they've just
given up
on the the process of
how a democratic republic works through
and solves these problems
i think you've got a lot of bullies who
want power and have found a path they
found a pitchfork and a torch and
they've gone with it
and i think it's funny that you know for
most of my life i was
pretty much on the left now that we're
you know we're coming into the situation
where
trump is evil and you know uh you know
he's he's the next coming of hitler and
all of nonsense
a an honest take on that and they say
your right wing
or or it's everything's just so so
absolutely binary like right
now there's articles talking about
people who are supporting conspiracy
theories
specifically if you believe there was
fraud in the election
and so if you are honest about the news
you're right wing that's where we're at
right now and so i took that famous line
and i said reality has a right-wing bias
at least it does today
what was it colbert who said reality is
a left-wing bias you know what 15 or so
years ago
maybe it did back then but today when i
pull up you know
cnn and they just say no evidence of
fraud at all
and then i literally have a sworn
affidavit six of them
all dropped at one time well witness
testimony under oath is is is evidence
the media is lying about this stuff just
because you mentioned him real quick as
a sideline
who do you think is the first of these
comedians or
show hosts no the existing ones today
who basically just made their
milk and honey out of trump for the past
four years which of them
gets the axe first samantha bee it has
to be right
i mean it's just they're all so bad and
they're spread so thin and their jokes
are the same
and they're so tired and everybody's i
mean frankly colbert was very close to
being fired i believe just because of
his
ratings at the time prior to trump
getting elected and turning so political
and you know and i i mean i've loved
colbert during his
career i've met him and he's been very
kind to me and that kind of thing
but at the same time it's like you
became so one note and so partisan and
so politicized
you stopped making jokes and and to me i
i look at that whole situation and it's
like
can we maybe get some good comedy back
in here you had ryan long in here the
other day
he's hilarious i've interviewed before
too he's absolutely hilarious you see
the instagram just pulled his video down
whoa really which one uh three days ago
which video it was pulled down maybe but
it's on youtube
no he was like guess he got to go to
youtube to see my new video that
instagram pulled down oh my gosh but
he's a good example of something
like there's so many comedians who
i mean and many of them are are leftists
you know but comedy itself is anti-woke
in in
all of its respects i mean it's designed
to cut people down it's designed to
you know make these points and to me
looking at this
landscape of hackery i just
we deserve a show that actually makes us
laugh firstly because comedians are
smart
and that these people have given up i
think a lot of people on the left that
are crazy and you were like have they
given up
it's like they got to a puzzle it's like
okay it's a d you get to a puzzle and
it's
so complex you can't figure it out and
you're just like
i don't know and then you choose bash as
your option and you just smash it to get
through and that's what they're doing
they're going woke
and they're just bashing because it's
it's the the
military-industrial complex the
pharmaceutical industry
all these industries the media the
manipulation they're hearing different
things
is so confusing to these people that
they're just giving up and then they're
just choosing so
go woke let's just go so ryan long's
video was
white women say go back to hating white
men okay so i
actually was doing really well i just i
had just saved that on
on my youtube before i came over here
today to remind myself to watch it
but that's that's crazy they pull
something like that that's
that sounds hilarious obvious jokes but
you know what they allow
they'll well i'm not gonna get into it
they allow bodily fluids and and certain
things
like what they choose to allow and not
allow is really weird
like honestly in my opinion the nipple
thing is kind of funny
there was like there were so they're
kind of amusing women who take
um like they're like vinyl stickers of
male nipples
over their nipples and that's approved
by instagram what
because like because the rules are like
this weird system where it's like male
nipples are okay female aren't what the
heck
right it's kind of it's weird isn't it
it's like i just gotta allow the nipple
man you gotta
i guess you have to allow it i don't
know what you do because it makes no
sense they do that because then it looks
like they're just topless anyway you
know
you're still insinuating i think the
simulated nudity is just like nudity
right
i don't know that's how it's treated our
minds i think the rules are all really
weird
yes but but again stupid rules we're
surrounded by stupid rules and some
sometimes they have the force of
government behind them but we're
increasingly surrounded by stupid rules
from places that really ought to be more
in the business of just like
we're a place where you can charge for
your newsletter all right
so so this is funny right it's always
been the liberals that were like the
corporations
the corporations and you know we got to
tax the companies and
stop them and the government is good
then for a long time it was always the
conservative saying no the free market
is okay the corporations are not evil
and the government i'm
speaking generally of course now it's
the democrats saying but my private
business
it's like you sound like the koch
brothers and they and they think you're
they all think you're stupid
i mean jeff bezos you know yeah you know
it's like
oh amazon is viewed as horrible that's
so bad i'm gonna
buy the washington post with basically
my money i found
with my couch oh and let's put democracy
dies and darkness at the top right at
the top
and we'll have all these stories bashing
trump and we'll you know market it
through amazon as like a bonus to people
meanwhile we're going to put out a
business small businesses all over the
place
and we're going to crush them when it
comes to ip we're going to engage in all
of this negative behavior and you're not
going to care because
we're just anti-trump we're this time
the fascists we're fighting them but so
this is why i think we're on the
precipice
well i can't keep using that analogy i
said before i feel like we've splattered
on the ground we felt the precipice we
went over a long time ago
we were falling for a long time smack
the ground this country has been split
in two
and you've got people i i have more than
two it's fragrance no no
it is but just speaking generally the
people who supporting joe biden
who are supporting the lockdowns and
there's a large overlap not not every
single but the venn diagram is pretty
you know tightly compact allowing
private businesses to take away
to to monopolize the commons that is the
most anti-leftist thing i've ever heard
but the left supports it
not all leftists but for the most part
they deny the censorship is even
happening
they say things like it's a private
business they can do what they want and
i'm like
bro the conversations we have the
marketplaces that's called the commons
it's the area of con
where it's supposed to be like for all
of us to work and live together the left
was always about defending that
now you're saying but private business
when they censor somebody take away
their banking
or even in some instances kick them out
of their apartments which has happened
to some people
that's how crazy things are getting
they're supporting it so you know what i
see
stupid and complicit people the priests
of the cathedral who know what they're
doing and manipulate these people
and then you end up with the
i guess you call it the red pilled
that's the that's the analogy they use
it's not not all conservatives i think
conservatives were the ones who woke up
to this a long time ago because they
were being lied about quite a bit
but then you end up with disaffected
liberals people like me you're certainly
no conservative you're
further left than i am on a lot of
issues and you would be considered right
wing for a lot of things that's insanity
it is it is look at you you're you're a
hippie dude skateboard shirt with long
hair and then
your right wing dude but this is what's
right they're gone they don't mean it of
course
they're vague but think about what's
happening now what is
someone to do when you are watching
amazon eviscerate the working class
laughing while they do it democracy dies
in darkness
as he spits in your face and they
advocate and
and and fund politicians who say it's
against the science but we're gonna
destroy your life your small business
your family
we're going to tell you to wear a mask
in your own home between bites but
we're going to go out and party like
gavin newsom what's a regular person
going to do when they see that over and
over again
and they know because they're listening
they're paying attention people are
going to explode
man i was on uh fox news earlier today
uh in uh the noon hour and they were
talking about niro tandon
the appointee or the expected appointee
to
head the omb office of management budget
underneath joe biden
uh and nira is obviously somebody who
you know about
and uh is uh russia very controversial
when it comes to
both her association with hillary
clinton her activities running the
center for american progress her general
trollishness
toward people online and as the
democrat who was on the show leslie
marshall was defending her
she said you know she's backed by you
know as qualified by such a diverse
you know coalition of people including
hillary clinton and bill crystal
and i just and i literally i literally
said you could fly this clip i
started going like into my microphone
just for people don't know who's bill
crystal
the former the former head of the now
defunct uh weekly standard
but also someone who you know is also a
major neoconservative figure
you know has argued for wars all around
the world and
very similar to hillary to me it's well
but
i said look you know the fact that you
think that these two people coming
together to back near a tandem is an ar
as a mark in her favor
you know tells us a lot about what this
where this administration is going which
is what i
here's what i honestly think we have we
have a situation where
the the america last foreign policy the
people who
view everything through the global
sphere as opposed to what is in the
interests of
the american people who view war as
something that we should go into
you know on the other side people who
view war is something that we should go
into very reluctantly very rarely and
always with
the interests of americans and the
american uh
and american stability uh you know at
heart in other words
you know there's a higher level of
threat from the cartels than from a lot
of these
countries in africa that's a side point
but the
the point being i think that that's now
moved into this new
this center-left globalist uh
coalition that biden wants to form and
that the kamala harris folks wants to
want to form in his stead
uh which is we're going to be good to
big tech we're going to be good to big
wall street
we're going to do everything that they
want in terms of of globalism and get
back into
you know the paris climate accords which
china likes more than us
which you know get back into the iran
deal you know get back into all these
other things that other places want that
don't look out for american interests
and they really think that they can hold
that together
with the glue of progressive wokism
there's a a reporter for the atlantic
who blocked me recently
because uh i quote tweeted him in a
critical
critical of the media in general but uh
we're seeing something quite a bit where
they're saying there's this meme going
around the journalists say
if uh the past four years of trump was
like drowning in a vat of tabasco sauce
then the next stories of biden will be
like sipping unflavored almond milk and
everyone laughs like haha joe biden is
going to be so
so boring right so joe biden hurts his
ankle
okay and this reporter for the atlantic
posts
an image saying joe biden playing with
dog hurts ankle and he says
you know an image of how boring the next
several years are going to be and then
he does this joke where it's like 2019
donald trump extra extra legally calls
for an investigation of
saturday night live because they made a
critical you know sketch about him
20 20 21 you know joe biden plays with
the dog something like that
so my response was 2011 barack obama
orders drone strike on civilian cafe and
country we are not at war with killing a
16 year old american citizen and his
response to the public is oopsie
2020. joe biden's transition team is
looking a lot like barack obama's team
so we're going to get obama 2.0
point being journalists are basically
telling us they're not going to do their
jobs totally
they're already saying it's so funny
playing with a dog meanwhile it's like
okay
should we count down the days until he
blows up some kids i mean it's like bets
it's definitely a situation where you're
going to have
them using oh there's a there's a rescue
pet
you know oh look at look at the funny
socks oh you know uh
tony blinken he he plays the guitar
that's the thing that we're going to
talk about the next secretary of state
and it's like shouldn't aren't there
more important things that are
going to need to be addressed here i
mean the most significant obviously
being
i still have no idea what joe biden's
secret plan
and the coronavirus looks like that one
it just seems to be yell on the phone
via you know at uh governors to have
more mask mandates
now we can play the the partisan game
and i can say
i just read a story that joe biden heard
his ankle playing with doug what is this
man doing playing with a dog during one
of the most
the worst pandemics we've ever
experienced shouldn't he be working on
something instead of playing around
with you play silly games criticize him
for whatever you can
but that's that's like the the partisan
that's that's the partisan media run
barack obama admits
that he was smoking throughout his
entire tenure right at the white house
no no i wish um but
maybe you want to kill somebody honestly
it would probably been a much better
peace pipe but but seriously
the fact that we never knew that when
everyone was so
like picking apart uh trump's like i
think they always lie about the
presidency
i always say he's healthier i think
jacob tapper jake tapper was like
something happened
jake tapper called him out and got
ridiculed for it
uh like years ago he said i smelled
smoke on obama and then they all made
fun of him i think it was tapper
and now he's like i do recall this yes
um but it's but it's like that's what
they're gonna do again
they're gonna totally because it's fine
a tan suit oh that was the only scandal
oh that was criticizing him so the tan
suit thing uh
is uh total fake news fiction it's like
a handful of people made fun of the
fan suit and then everybody has now put
like the tan suit was this huge scandal
on the right
and it's like it was literally a hint i
remember jokes i remember interestingly
we have a uh
lukewarm is hanging out he was at i
think it was like a d and it was a
debate or something a dancing convention
and he asked a couple democrats about
the extrajudicial assassination
by barack obama of a 16 year old
american citizen whose name was abdul
rahman al-awlaki
and it was camera the guy's name is
charlie gibbs is that his name
he said well he should have had a better
father the
so so so the questions that wrote
that is a hot take a 16 year old
american
from denver colorado lived in san diego
was visiting his grandparents in yemen
barack obama ordered a drone strike in
yemen we're not at war with yemen
blowing up a civilian restaurant we
don't target civilians
killing a 16 year old american citizen
what the don't target kids
talk about scandals somebody that obama
wanted debt right yeah he was uh
suspected of being like a high profile
like uh jihadist so the theory is they
killed the guy's son
well the the anti-war activists think
that barack obama was basically telling
the world
if you f with us i will kill your kids
and he's willing to block civilians to
do it it's so funny how
though the the media complex pretended
that trump's approach of foreign policy
was going to be
something that dragged him down that was
this negative around him
with the american people when it is so
much more historically in sync with what
americans tend to want
which is they they do they are not
peacenix okay they
they go through periods of after heavy
wards of being you know sort of looking
like peaceniks
but in reality they tend to be as walter
russell mead is written consistently
jacksonian
which is that if you leave us alone and
you don't screw with us
then we won't we don't want to go over
there and screw with you and have it
come back and you know
have it be complicated and that kind of
thing uh we just want you to leave us
alone but if you screw with us we're
going to come over and we're just going
to you know
and we're armed beat the crap out of you
for and
more and and that's what they like but
then they don't like to
stay around and exist in these
nation-building ways
and in fact george w bush made that same
argument when he was running for
president in 2000 he said
we don't want to be in the nation
building business anymore that type of
thing wow
exactly that's how it worked out for him
um go back and find that clip
well but i think that that's another
indication where
there is a that is the undercurrent
because it's actually pretty consistent
with frankly a lot of people who come
from military families
want it's the fact that they don't want
their kid to be sent over to some small
war they understand the purpose of
defending america
they're patriots they want the country
to be defended they don't want to
you know get rid of the military or you
know shut that all down
at the same time they don't want to hear
about their kid
dying in africa as we saw you know a
little more than a year ago and have
senators come on the camera and say
i didn't even know that we were in this
part of africa you know and that's what
happened and it's like
that should disgust us we should never
have a situation where that happens it's
the first time i've heard of that you
know you know
we had a we had a lefty on the show and
he was like 26.
we were talking about joe biden's you
know
as a vice president in these scandals
and he was like i think i was 15 or 16
when that happened
so so a lot of these totally and and i'm
experiencing
this now because i am an old man at 38.
um and
uh and i have employees now who
were you know two years old when nine
eleven have yeah three years old
uh and uh you know they don't even you
know when
when one of my colleagues makes a
reference to team america world police
and they have no idea what you're
talking about
which is really depressing it's like
what you're all doing what is this
puppet sex move
that you're talking about anyway yeah
the only way i would sleep with you is
if you promised me you would never die
i will never die the
the thing that is amazing about it is
you start to see
how uh and i didn't listen to people who
were older than me and who told me this
our politics repeats so much yeah it has
this rhyming quality to it
where we come back to these same points
with new figures
and new elements but they also repeat in
these fascinating ways
and you know oftentimes i think you end
up having these
controversial in the time figures who in
retrospect
prove to be viewed as incredibly
effective
or having done amazing things you know
reagan was one of these figures
clinton became one of these figures i
think in retrospect people look back and
they're like wow that bill clinton he
was you know
very centrist and sort of did these
cultural culturally slightly
conservative things and
you know had these attitudes in
different directions at the time he was
the most controversial person
we've ever seen in the presidency and
republicans
hated him and loathed him and
investigated the crap out of him and
impeached him
and i think in in retrospect we'll look
back we'll come to look back on trump
as being a similar figure in a lot of
respects he governed
closer to the center than people
actually many people are saying you know
how many
uh months or years until ellen is you
know sharing candy with trump at a
baseball game or something
soon but i think it'll be biden first
well look george w
bush in that famous you know bit with
the saying the candy who will it be
who will it be because it won't be
somebody who's conservative like vince
vaughn it'll be someone who's a little
bit more who will it be
it's it's crazy to me that if you look
at the things george w bush did and dick
cheney compared to what trump did
it's just like night and day and here
they are there was a poll that came out
that said democrats
view george w bush more favorably than
trump and i'm like
y'all have lost oh my gosh but this is
why i just don't listen no no no this is
why i brought up
the dude yes but when you have when you
have people who are
you got 20 year olds who voted 20 year
olds who are activists online
online right now marching down the
street right there waving better this is
when we got into iraq
yeah and they were ten they were they
were they were they were uh
what eight years old during the economic
crisis they were 10 years old in 2010
they were 11 during occupy wall street
so while we're on occupy wall street and
you've got the left rising up
complaining about obama and both
democrats and republicans
and we got all of these years look the
the emergence of black lives matter and
all this stuff happened under obama
the national guard being deployed all of
it's under obama we had these riots
we had uh you know libya syria all of
these conflicts
you have stories about drone strikes
they called him obama
obamber like bombing people they called
him the deporter-in-chief
here we are we get trump not good in the
first few years in foreign policy
improving
very much so in the in the last two
years firing bolton especially bringing
up all the time it was a great move
shouldn't hire him in the first place
and then i'm talking to these these
people who are now in their 20s and
they're like
i was 10 when all that was happening and
i'm like so you you come into my
house we've been fighting this fight
against these insane
these insane people you know hillary
clinton was told a no-fly zone over
syria would mean world war three war
with russia and she was like basically
so what
so you know what you just touched on
there is is one of the
the great ironies of trump's presidency
which is that
uh to the degree that it was a failure
um
it is because he failed to do the very
thing he was most famous for
before gaming into the presidency which
is fire people oh
yes if he had fired james comey on day
one
oh yeah you don't have all of that you i
don't trust that
he trusted too many people if if if you
fire or never hire bolton you don't have
that period
if you fire anthony fauci the minute
that he comes out and says we're not
we shouldn't reopen schools despite the
rest of the first world
reopening schools i mean there's a lot
of different things that could have gone
right here if trump had been quicker to
fire people
if he had and if he had actually been
almost if he would if it was even an one
one degree towards more authoritarian as
much as they claim him to be
but and in addition it's the funny thing
is that that's the actual
i would argue the same thing of george w
bush you know uh
michael brown and katrina you know heck
of a job brownie
he should have fired him almost
immediately as it became clear that he
was not cut out to run fema in this
situation
you know he he declined firing rumsfeld
you know when rumsfeld was willing to go
like there's a number of instances where
he kind of stuck with people out of
personal loyalty
and it ended up backfiring i just think
that this is
it's again it's one of those situations
where things rhyme and people
people end up getting cowardice bush was
a coward he had cheney around the
military
trump's a coward he doesn't he wants
people to like him so he won't make hard
decisions
i wouldn't necessarily say cowardice
it's more
there's we forget sometimes that
politicians are
are human and i think that one of the
things that animates them so much it's
similar to actors
uh no offense to mr page is that they
have this
deep hole in their heart that needs to
be filled with something
whether that's adulation or praise or
affirmation
i mean there's a reason that so many
great politicians have parents who are
drunks
that describes donald trump he puts his
name in giant gold letters and types of
buildings all over the world
yeah and the joke is that he you know
his he was neglected
i mean the left argues he was literally
abused he was letting bolton
run the show until he saw that people
hated him on twitter he's like oh
gotta get rid of him so people like me
so what the american conservative wrote
fire bolton hired tulsi
and i was clapping i'm like yes like
absolutely get rid of this guy but i
think that this is a situation where
once again
we we now have a political situation
that is dominated by the olds by the
people who have nothing in common with
all the people who you were just talking
about
yep we have we had three presidents from
the same birth year
1946 okay it had it had george w bush it
had bill clinton and it had donald trump
they were all born
within seven months of each other and um
and if you think about it they're all
kind of the different
aspects of boomer ism yeah like clinton
the kind of you know hippie higher ed
you know draft dodger
you know george w kind of the the
miscreant like the guy who kind of had a
rough time but then kind of made good
frat boy yeah and then trump is kind of
the rat pack
you know hold over you know over-the-top
vegas you know
where are the young people in this in
this you know well we just went older
we just went to our first silent
generation era we went
older than the baby boom he snapped his
foot playing with his dog
seriously no no no no no listen i'm
gonna say it again joe biden is the
worst thing to happen to this country
for like listen there's a lot of i'm
sure joe's fine in a lot of ways he's
bad in a lot of ways
but for what this country is going
through right now the worst possible
thing that could happen is joe biden you
know why because he's free
every every republican hates him or or
for the most part doesn't like him
and half the democrats don't like him he
only got elected
arguably from the right they'll say
because of fraud but in the surface
level approach
people voted against trump yes against
trump meaning at a time when we are more
polarized than ever and we need strong
leadership to unite us
what we get is nothing we have no
president we have no legal voted
i really i really say this with hope
that it is not true
but the worst president in american
history in my pers from my perspective
is james buchanan
and obviously he led to civilization a
long time ago can you explain why
james buchanan was was a a feckless and
uh corrupt
sort of guy who you know really was
completely unprepared for the kind of
strife that was coming in
into the country ultimately he was
obviously followed by abraham lincoln
and we immediately went into civil war
because of it now i'm not predicting
that and i want to make clear that i'm
not predicting that but this
it has a similar flavor to it of someone
who is just
elected in in for a lot of reasons that
don't have to do with him and then
shows himself to be very ill-suited for
the historic moment that he inhabits
and i really worry that that's what
we're facing right now
maybe donald trump convinces look
pennsylvania says they're not going to
come into session
they say we need five days for a joint
resolution maybe trump
gets a lightning strike three times
georgia maybe
wisconsin and arizona but guess what
it's really interesting no one's that
lucky in the casino
hey i i look i i've been saying it since
the seventh
like i think it's astronomically likely
it's going to be or i i shouldn't say
that i shouldn't say it that way
the odds extremely in joe biden's favor
to the point where it's like 99.99
but the reason i reserved that little
bit actually early on i said it was
probably like 97
because trump still had these lawsuits
and he still had the states weren't
certified
now we're at a point where it's like
winning the lottery three times in a row
for trump to pull it off
i wouldn't say never i wouldn't say
never because listen listen we had these
hearings
okay and people are freaked out it
doesn't mean it's likely at all
it just means the door here's the way i
put it
there's a track that trump is on at the
end of that there's a gleam men
there's a team yes there's a train track
trump's train is on it and it is headed
towards a door that means
re-election but in between are
loop-de-loops
jumps boulders trees falling over and
it's like
i don't see it making there maybe
have you extremely unlikely have you
looked back at the election of 1876
yes yes that was when they appointed a
council to determine the president
it was amazing absolutely crazy but it
also puts in perspective how
like i know 1876 seems like a long time
ago but that's just shows
like our american bodies you know like
like there are people who are who are
walking around
who's like that was their grandpa who
was around you know during like
the presidency i was i was listening to
the radio once and it was a beer
commercial it was an import and they
were like
our beer is protected by the you know
fine beer law of 1217 and i was like
wow like the united states doesn't go
back that far you know
we are so incredibly young as a nation i
was just thinking
in order for us to have a normal
conversation just talk about this stuff
we have to have our own social network
it has to be a mesh network so we don't
have an isp we have to be on
the banking system and have crypto only
because the banks can all shut us down
we have to have our own electricity on
site
and our own water supply on site because
the government can shut off our water
and water
but just to have a normal conversation
publicly but listen if
you if you actually you know these
people the green new deal types and the
leftists
everything you describe should be
exactly what they're striving for
get people off the grid so that they're
self-sustainable get people
why do we have lawns just grass and then
we do we mow the grass and we throw it
in the compost where are we going to
grow our own food yeah i want to grow
potatoes
what if you turn your front lawn into a
potato field and you have then you have
food
you don't have to grow potatoes you can
go buy stuff with crypto but if you
can't
turn your crypto into cash fiat because
you don't have a bank
i i won the stripe or the swift payment
system has cut you out has banned your
person
right right right and if and if we all
became more self-sufficient that would
have less of an impact on us
if we could grow our own food if we had
our own energy in our homes
just so you can talk without being
censored but do you think that the
do you think though that the the
lockdowns and everything have been
have improved the possibility of that or
no it decreased
yes it's now you got people saying
government why won't you give me free
food
exactly exactly i got a guard in my
backyard you know
look we moved i moved out to the middle
of nowhere because
i don't want to be forced to live under
their boot
when they start locking you down telling
you can and can't go to the store you
can't go out at night
you eventually run out of the limited
food you have living in the city
and then you're just sitting there
saying please government can i now eat
okay can i can i speak to that the
so i uh was born in mississippi grew up
a little bit in south carolina and then
we moved to rural virginia which is
actually about
you know an area where uh
before the big tech boom
before all of these companies moved in
it was all rural farmland and farmland
that was starting to be chopped
up into into suburbs but still homes
that had tons of of land and the like
and living in that area you were
surrounded by
two types of people um you know
a very rural area basically it was
people who their families had lived
there
for ages they were used to being
incredibly self-sufficient
you know when winter came if they were
up you know sort of in the blue ridge
they could you know live up there and be
fine for ages
and then you had these people who were
moving there often from california and
the like
to staff these jobs at then it was aol
and mci worldcom and places like that
that were the first ones coming in and
the differences between the kids
could not have been greater in terms of
expectations about
life and what was self-sufficiency and
things like that and seeing the early
stages
of like helicopter parenting as a trend
at the same time that there were
families where it was like oh yeah the
little kid they'll just go off and
they'll take care of themselves and
they'll come back
total divide and i feel like as a
country we're seeing that
helicopter approach just completely take
over and the
and the worry that i've had and i've
said this since this whole thing began i
had a conversation with a friend of mine
um who does a great podcast called the
fifth column
um and we were going back and forth and
he said you know i'm worried that we're
gonna see
revolution we're gonna see people with
guns in the streets
you know and that they're going to be
fighting and killing politicians and
things like
i said my worry is they're just going to
go along with all this
because the american people are too
docile now they don't have that
self-sufficiency gene anymore it's been
smothered
and i just think that everything that's
happened since it's vindicated
i i have said over and over again that
republicans will probably just roll over
you know put their feet up and accept
accept it because
and i mean they're republican
politicians they're kind of yes that is
their business that is their nature
yeah that's the frog scorpion the the
people
i uh uh um the people i think are gonna
get angry
yes so so so i was taught we're out in
the middle of nowhere
and i was talking to a guy who lives
kind of kind of a bit of ways away
but i would consider to be relatively
local because we're in the middle of
nowhere
and he was man you could see it in his
eyes
just like he's ready he said if donald
trump told me
you know come out bring your weapons and
i was like dude
dude whoa but reuters ran a story saying
something similar
that they interviewed trump supporters
and they said if trump trump need only
give the word and they'll be out with
their guns
that's the regular american and that i
mean look i believe it because that's
what america was
america was founded by people who are
like fu government yeah right
yeah so did you did you see the whole
principle that the only thing good about
that
mark wahlberg remake of the of the
gambler is uh the speech that john
goodman gives about how america is built
on the principle of
fu yeah you have an army you're the
biggest empire in the world
f you did you see the uh uh we're the
story the we the people convention
did you see this yes this is this letter
so we have this ad exercise they say we
the people convention
exercising extraordinary authority in
defense of our vote may be required
because martial law is better than civil
war
they gonna talk about what lincoln did
he ordered hundreds of northern
newspapers that spoke against him to be
shut down
lincoln ordered the arrest of ohio
congressman clement
valen dingham for the crime of speaking
out against him
chief justice of the u.s roger uh chief
chief justice of the u.s roger taney
ruled
that lincoln had violated the us
constitution when he illegally suspended
the writ of habeas corpus
after hearing this lincoln signed an
arrest warrant to have the chief justice
of the u.s arrested
lincoln ordered the arrest of thousands
in maryland for the crime
of suspected southern sympathies
including ordering the arrest of u.s
congressman henry may from maryland
these people were arrested and held in
military prisons without trial
some of them for years and he had a war
to win
and and guess what there are people who
are calling for this right now
the point of this ad being taken out was
to tell trump to do it
they say we have well-funded armed and
trained marxists and antifa and blm
strategically positioned in our major
cities acting openly with violence to
silence opposition for their
anti-american agenda
attacking federal buildings and police
cowardly punching innocent people i mean
i'm not going to read this whole thing
let me let me let me read you this but i
think you're right
that biden is this incompetent
lackluster that
for four years it's gonna brew and
someone is going to do well
the problem is just look at the reaction
that was the non-reaction that we saw
during the summer
which i would actually argue is the
point where any of the honest polls
started to be completely wrong because
white people in wisconsin who you're
trying to pull on your attitude towards
blm are absolutely not going to tell you
that they hate it
um but the reaction from biden was
basically
come on man stop setting stuff on fire
to be fair his his reaction was more uh
trinidad shot at a pressure
so he's like buchanan this this crap
nobody
it's it's the sort of situation where i
think you have these
to your to what you were just saying you
have these things brewing
and festering and getting more and more
intense and then when they
when things start burning and the flame
turns up here's the thing
white cops have not stopped shooting
unarmed black men
someone will that will happen you know
within the next couple of months
now it'll happen to it happens to a much
lesser degree than you would think that
it happens based on the media
but the way that that it plays out and
this response that biden has to it
you know what is he going to do this is
going to be a situation where he's
caught between
the defund the police side of things
that is frustrated and and doesn't like
the fact that they're being blamed for
democrat losses
and this octogenarian leadership that
democrats have
and nancy pelosi and the head of the
heads of the house
it's it's amazing that we have this
by the way matt stoler i think had a
great tweet about them naming
janet yellen uh to treasury uh secretary
he's like
finally the octogenarians of the
democratic leadership are passing it
along to the younger septuaginarians
but seriously i don't think that he can
manage that situation if he
if he does we can all you know raise our
hands and say hey
you know thank god for joe biden but i
just think that this is this is not a
moment that demanded this it's a moment
that demanded a lot
more leadership let me let me read this
beginning of this ad
talking about calling it's calling on
trump to declare martial law and they
say
on june 12 1863 lincoln defended his
extreme measures in a letter published
in the new york times
citing article 1 of the constitution he
argued ours is a case of rebellion in
fact
a clear flagrant and gigantic case of
rebellion
and the provision of the constitution
that quote the privilege of the writ of
habeas corpus shall not be suspended
unless when
in cases of rebellion or invasion the
public safety may require it
is the provision which specifically
applies to our present case
lincoln used the same reasoning to in
justif justifying a series
of extraordinary presidential orders you
know the
uh i would encourage people to i don't
i think you know lincoln had uh a very
different context than the current
moment
it literally had seven states secede
from the yes i mean i just don't think
that we're going to and we shouldn't
pretend that we are but what i do think
is
we we invest way too much in our
politicians and we have
as a nation for far too long we define
ourselves
by who our president is when i think we
should be defined by
who we are as neighbors and who we are
in our communities and what those look
like because they're closer to home
but go ahead i i think we need to return
more to uh
local level politics the way the con the
country was originally founded there's a
there's a cs lewis line though about the
dangers of newspapers
you know the the main media of his day
where he says that the problem
with them is that they bring all the
sorrows of the world to your doorstep
every morning and and instead and you
focus
on paraphrasing but he basically says
and and that dominates your focus as
opposed
uh to the neighbor to the friend to the
place that you can walk to where you can
actually make a difference
and that to me that sorrows of all the
world thing is
is totally what animates this current
dominating leadership factor that says
you know we need to be everywhere and
solving everything in
every aspect of every life as the
federal government right
as opposed to saying you know the the
the gestures in the line
your pop the politicians you care about
the most should be close enough to kick
yeah well so uh originally you know
before the 17th amendment
senators were appointed yes they were
voted on by the state legislatures
and then sent because we lived in a
state and we were citizens of a state
that was part of a union so we would
vote for this at the state level
and then things would move on up same
thing with electoral college we were in
the state we had our electors we voted
for them
then they went and we trusted them to do
the right thing now everything
is all about the federal government and
you've got republicans who understand
the difference
and are like leave me alone and the left
who thinks we're just one big country
period
they don't understand the point of
jurisdictions and states and sovereignty
yeah
somewhere somewhere uh some person is
doing
something that i think is totally wrong
from my apartment in brooklyn
uh and even if i've never been to that
state or heard of this place before
right now i'm very bad about it and i'm
going to be very loud online to get it
to change
remember when i think it was uh i don't
remember exactly what triggered it but
you had that you know beta o'rourke you
know heck yes we're gonna take your guns
and then you know by
pointing them you're that guy who
tweeted what am i supposed to do if if
they take away my air 15 yes
what am i supposed to do if 13 to 50
what was it feral
have you heard the interviews with the
guys since then no no no oh they're
phenomenal so some
basically uh i think it was either radio
lab or one of these other podcasts
dug into found this guy interviewed him
a couple of times and talked about this
very real incident he had 30 to 50.
30 to 50 where where all of these feral
hogs had come into the backyard and he
had to run out
you know and shoot his gun to scare them
away from his kids who were playing out
there
and then what was funny about the
podcast is like this this you know
again new york based i think uh uh you
know
interviewer starts researching the whole
feral hog problem
and suddenly discovers that like it's a
real thing this is a real thing
it's a huge deal lots of people care
about it
and it's really controversial in places
like oklahoma
and um and they live in they live in an
urban bubble
yeah i was having a conversation with
someone uh there was there was an
argument on facebook
and these people were arguing about guns
and stuff and the one person's like it's
ridiculous
you know guns need to be controlled and
then i responded with where i live
why i live in the middle of nowhere who
do i call no no i have guns i have many
many guns and
and we're elevated and we have excellent
positioning i made a joke
uh recently uh it wasn't a joke it was
like i didn't know what it was called i
called it a dear sniper tower
and then all of the conservatives who
know it's a deer blind started laughing
and i'm like i don't know it's just a
tower you shoot from so i called it a
sniper tower
yeah dear blind we we we actually have i
have several friends including
a couple of my employees who hunt feral
hogs regularly because they're lots of
fun to hunt um
but but it's a really good example of
why we have different laws in different
jurisdictions
why a a republic makes so much sense
not a big feral hog problem in in
brooklyn or basically exactly and so so
if brooklyn says we're going to have
these certain restrictions on certain
things not necessarily guns because the
second amendment but let's say they're
like we don't want people riding around
on you know uh
you know electric skateboards or
whatever because this thing happens
well if you live in the middle of
nowhere like skateboard's not an issue
you might have a different law for it it
makes sense
what's happening now is with with the
left and democrats thinking we're just
one big country they're like
everyone should have like no guns all
guns banned you just need to think of
feral hogs the same way that
you think of bike lanes it's a local
nuisance for
free to deal with and then but again
the the government that is closest to
the people governs best
and and governs i think most honestly
and in this in this situation
we have nationalized everything with a
media
that has fewer and fewer outlets across
the country i mean this
this year we had reporters on the ground
covering
uh the election to the extent that it
was happening uh in 29 states
okay and that's with an organization of
you know 14 people
and uh and you know a bunch of of
stringers and
freelance contributors and so frequently
they would run into scenarios where they
were on the ground
and cnn would leave and all of these
sort of
national places would come in do a quick
hit and then they would get out
and you saw that most crazily in the in
the kenosha incident
yes right where you had that new york
times reporter
who was there already to cover it and
she told the daily
you know i was told by some of the cops
they thought it would be worse tonight
so i left and i went home and so why do
we have the footage that we have
because of outlets that didn't even
exist 20 years because of real
journalists because of daily caller
journalists
because of town hall because of uh bg on
the ground because of yeah richie
mcginnis
who actually did people who did that and
they're like those people were leaving
at 7 00 p.m when it was getting dark
we're like we're just getting started
and that was the basis for everything
that we knew about that situation
and we'll obviously figure in kyle
rittenhouse's trial
and like that's how the new york times
fails us that's how these
these entities fail us the new york
times did one good thing when they
analyzed the
the video feeds that was great okay but
but they weren't there
and what they don't tell you is that
when we actually had the dc riot crew
here talking about it what we learned
from
not just that group which is the daily
caller uh group of journalists but some
other journalists are on the ground too
is that in kenosha the the the rioters
had set a dumpster on fire and were
pushing it into a gas station
and the kyle rittenhouse and his group
were putting the fires out
and that's why he got attacked that's
why he was chased
that's why some dude fired into the air
whatever he turned around
returned fire it was because they were
pushing a flaming dumpster into a gas
station we had
multiple witnesses on the show tell us
that new york times doesn't talk about
that no it's not it's not in the
mainstream
and in the minds of of the corporate
media and many people have obviously
said this
oh yeah i know he was like some white
supremacist or something like that
and now the daily beast is saying you
know joe biden called for unity they
said
you want me unify with the supporters of
white supremacist kyle rittenhouse and
it's like
well you're wrong this is what i was
saying before about the low information
side they don't actually know because i
don't there's a variety of reasons they
lie
they're activists or they just genuinely
don't pay attention covington
you know the covington kids incident is
a good example but what happens when you
have
people like us that are substantially
better informed
eventually someone's going to be like we
can't just sit back and let dumb people
run everything
into the ground crash the plane well but
the split that you were talking about
before you said that the two and you
said it was more
i would argue that you know basically
it's it's two splits that are our
significant population
there's a small population of of elite
establishment people who actually
run most of the things that happen in
the country consistently and then there
is a mass of people who are disaffected
and who can only really be brought in by
major moments
that animate them to pay attention to
politics which is something that trump
was
right and and something i would argue
that that coronavirus was in a way that
they were manipulated i think
by media and by big tech uh to come out
and vote for someone who they really
didn't know or particularly care for
but were scared into doing for a lot of
different reasons
anyway setting that aside that
disaffected group is the one that i'm
worried about navigating this next
period the most because they're not the
ones as we
were saying before who know about the
pronoun stuff who know that that's going
to impact their
work and the future of their kids who
don't have enough engagement and frankly
who have seen their kids be completely
destroyed
by this online fake form of education
uh that is you know the teachers unions
effectively forced
on an entire generation of kids and it's
going to have
long-ranging consequences for them it
looks like the economy with 27 trillion
in debt now
it looks like early you know the great
depression how many people got screwed
in the great depression a lot of people
lost
almost everything they lost everything
they weren't prepared for it
and if these people are just so checked
out this huge segment of people
have their money in mutual funds and
they're just letting a guy move their
money around for him
waiting for their retirement check dude
if if the dollar really crashes
it's the biggest debt we've ever seen
and it's just escalating they just
printed three trillion now they're
talking about doing another
another three trillion 900 902 billion
dollar
relief package gonna come out so this so
that bill
i mean it is gonna be such a mess it's
it's so hilarious to me how
the most bipartisan thing that
washington does
is spend your money they love to spend
your money
i was i was on this uh it was a think
tank uh gathering
uh and and i they were going down the
panel of like you know what do you
expect to come out of the next
uh two years and i was just like are you
kidding they're gonna spending a ton of
money
that's that's all that's going to happen
they're not going to pass anything that
fixes anything in any real way it's just
going to be money
so here is if these people aren't
prepared and we go through another
depression another
another stock market crash or whatever
could happen um that they go hungry and
go insane
and then and they don't live in the city
start eating each other not maybe
figuratively
they start doing no no people people
don't realize and pleasing to death in
their
10 10 plus million how many people in
the new york metro 13 million
i don't know what it is now it's changed
so much yeah that's true so
only about four hundred thousand a half
a million have left according to much of
the
different reports but i i purposely i
personally i think it's more than that
yeah and i only think that's gonna
accelerate based on just the initial
stuff that we have
from uh anvil the company that does this
cards that you use to go into the
different buildings
it's like way lower than they expected
in terms of people going into
office buildings it's like one-fifth or
one-fourth of what they expected
that is technically a good thing because
uh people don't realize what would
happen
if the supply chain into new york
completely shattered
yeah no food and and and no waste
removal
right and you'd people would be
literally eating each other
even in a matter of like weeks a week
maybe weeks or more even before
coronavirus i would walk out onto the
street
out of this you know beautiful uh sort
of apartment building
and there would be this giant pile of
trash
in philly and to me like that's one of
the reasons look i
i think new york is a great city okay
one of the greatest cities in the world
if not the greatest city in the world i
would argue a little bit for london as
being that but
um the experience of like
the high class people who are spending a
crap ton of money to live
in this area then still have to walk
outside and smell that garbage
every day like i'd rather live in the
country
where you know you walk out and you've
got sandy when it flooded
yeah lower that was when all the power
went out oh yeah and and
people were uh people were skating on
the like the knocked over bus station
but bus stands it was amazing that was
one day
the power was out for weeks wasn't it
i'm not sure i remember
there were there were two guys standing
outside of a bodega with like two by
fours
and there was a line and they were like
one person at a time and i went in
and the guy was like the perishables are
basically gone like the stuff in the
fridge the milk
sorry but the canned goods you can still
buy i was like wow they'd like
like there's no electricity at all and
they had guards out in front of the
building protecting it and i was like
cash only and
walk out that's amazing you know who got
their power turned on first
who upper west side it's all the super
rich people
they hired the money oh yeah well the
city's basically like this is where our
tax revenue is generated we better make
sure they can keep working
the city will come back i believe that
but it's going to take a lot longer than
people think it will
yeah yeah but will it come back in a way
that we would consider it to be like
coming back you know i think the fazio's
talking about taking the buildings
no because i i don't think it will come
back in the way the way people think it
will it will not be the way it was
um and i think a large part of that is
that people have realized
during the course of this period that
they can work from places that are a lot
nicer
where they have more flexibility where
they can be at a slight remove from
people
and i think that that is just ingrained
in a way in american consciousness
in a way that it wasn't before that
allows them to move to new places and
and you know say look i can find a
community of like-minded people and i
don't need to
spend as much as i was spending in new
york plus the taxes that they're going
to have to raise
in order to make up this huge revenue
split super chats
yes it's about time we ask the audience
what they have in mind
what up audience so if you are chilling
hit that like button subscribe hit the
notification bell and get your super
chats in now we're going to start going
through them
you know we we we can't go through
everybody as you know as often i say
this all the time but we try to
read as many as possible so let's read
some of these super chats
let's see gone paul uh gone fall says
the hearing today in ar confirms that
legislatures will fight
also a legislature in ar at the end at
the end said they had unofficial
hearings because no one would let them
they were also sent threats in ar what
was that a hearing in arkansas
but there was a hearing in arkansas i
didn't hear about that does he mean
arizona maybe no the hearing wasn't in
arizona
it was a michigan hearing today yeah but
there was an arizona one the other day
and that
i don't i didn't hear about an arkansas
one sorry all right i got one here but
we gotta issue a correction raven
writing desk says common sense died the
day the woman won
in the quartz because a coffee cup
didn't have a warning label it says it's
hot i remember that is that's a myth
that's not true i remember that so
the issue was that uh a woman was given
a
a cup of coffee that was boiling from
mcdonald's and
it she accidentally spilled it and what
had happened was
mcdonald's had been warned several times
that their coffee was
it was too hot mcdonald's said even
though people had been injured in the
past
the reason they maintained the boiling
temperature which was causing injuries
to many people
was because by the time they got to the
office the coffee was cold so they tell
everybody to make the coffee super hot
people had been complaining endlessly
mcdonald's they didn't care she
initially only asked
for them to cover the medical bills
because what reasonable person expects
to be handed
a a cup of boiling liquid because you
can drink it right she was a passenger
they denied her they wouldn't give her
medical expenses of like ten thousand
dollars and she suffered horrific burns
it wasn't like she spilled hot coffee it
was like her skin fell off and it was in
her lap
and so long story short she ended up
suing and winning a lot more and then i
think she even like donated a bunch of
it because it was not about
having caution hot on it it was like why
are you handing boiling cups of water to
people
anyway i love those uh i love those
mythical but
everyone knows about them yes they're so
good
we got the correction gone fall says i
meant to say a z sorry i always get it
mixed okay
okay so so the the arizona thing i
one of the things that i think people
will learn about coming out of this
experience is how
uh the laws that we have on the books
only offer for
recounts and audits that are automatic
at very low thresholds
for instance in in arizona it would have
had to be like under a thousand votes
uh for in terms of a difference for them
to have that triggered and there's not
a request process so this is one another
one of those things where
in the interim between this time and
then and the midterm
a lot of states need to look at how
we're going to look at and audit you
know elections that are close but
you know maybe have a little bit more of
a leeway here
for that kind of thing so someone said
to uh mick hatton says look at lin
look at lynnwood twitter it's apparently
fake news i guess referencing what bill
barr said
and there's a tweet from him he says
time to fire a.g bill barr lies about
dominion no action on epstein durham
hunter biden laptop or weiner laptop a
stolen election now being ignored we
need patriots helping donald trump if we
were to save our country and freedom
he went on to say perhaps i should have
kept my powder dry on bill barr until he
speaks formally or issues a press
release
the ap article is likely propaganda i
know for a fact it contains a number of
false statements about sydney powell
and her investigation we'll see i i
don't agree with that i think that the
ap
article is probably correct and it is in
barr's character to go to the ap
as opposed to some of the other places
that he has beef with but but consider
he said to this date we have not seen
evidence that would have changed he
speaks very carefully and intentionally
yes so
don't like cut that out we didn't
actually get to talk about durham did
you want to do that at all
uh we could a little bit we got super
chats to go through maybe
we might we might have kind of uh you
know missed the train on that yeah so
just
just real quickly i think that the
naming of durham as a special counsel
obviously keeps him
protected uh makes sure that he has
additional time i also think it's a
statement frankly of
failure in terms of the selection of him
that went so slow and never got us the
answers
during the time that i think it would
have mattered when it came to the
election
eve welcome says barr has blood on his
hands with ruby ridge and waco
his field to the constitution and our
nation is tenuous at best
this is interesting because you know i
didn't know this but i know a bunch of
conservatives when they when i bring up
barr and i'm like
i appreciate you know some of the things
he said he's you know
he's been reasonable and they're like
all bars horrible talking about waco
and you know getting the a lot of yeah i
don't want to get into the
horrific things he was involved with
burning those people alive protecting
federal agents who killed people
essentially things like that
you know i don't know too much about it
so another cog in the machine
oh man we got one for ian maybe so my
god this is awesome says ian you can be
the next superhero we need keep up the
energy hit the gym
wear a tim tim foil head and hang out
with alex jones and give him hell
okay i'm going to start doing push-ups
in the morning yes thank you yes do it
eat more protein teresa hoisington says
bar and derm are old busty
old bushy establishment they'll always
act in an old establishment way no
surprise
they are team analog turtle
i mean i don't i don't know durham
enough to be i don't really have a lot
of hope for anything coming out of this
but i do think that barr
without his presence in this
administration the president never would
have had a shot at reelection i think he
really turned a corner in a significant
way and was an indispensable
person in what he was able to achieve
delta 7 says this will not
push you guys to more secure voting the
experience we have here in latin america
with what you have now
is that once it this is accepted it will
only get worse
that's how it begun for us here yeah
i've been talking about blockchain
voting like a chicken with my head cut
off
i did get people did contact me with
some data on it which i can read now if
you guys want to hear anything
you want blockchain voting let me see
this well stop pulling up our reviews
let's see delta 7 says i'm sorry brubra
says y'all haven't seen anything yet
secret service have evidence that will
be coming out soon
inside info it implicates biden and
others in dnc
and that sounds very exciting i would
love to see it until then i'm gonna you
know i can't operate
on what i haven't seen and no evidence
so
delta seven says my impression is that
you are trying to play the leftist game
but not understand how they operate
it's not using logical reason we in
latin america did that mistake they
don't play by the rules
and they don't care well there's a
there's a
as long as we're talking about latin
america you know one of the dangers
that uh uh is in uh
jorge casanada's book uh that talks
about manana forever is that we will
become more like mexico
during this period and i don't mean that
as to denigrate mexico but basically
historically you have a situation there
where you have the powerful
and you have the mob and the mob appeals
to the powerful
asks for you know answers or redress or
essentially
you know to fix their problem and the
the powerful use this moment to their
advantage and that just repeats over and
over again and you replace the powerful
person with a new person
and part of that has to do with the fact
that they have very little civic
engagement they don't have the
kind of community organizations that you
would traditionally have and so you end
up with a situation where the cartel
basically runs the government
and yeah yeah and that are the cartels
are doing now
starting social media networks no no no
no no no no
the the cartels were big in drugs right
yes we started legalizing some of those
so you know they're trafficking now
kids people avocados avocados no joke
avocados it's just it's it's all about
the money it's not about yeah you know
illegal it's like can we make money
while the avocados are where it's
my favorite my favorite a brief
biden attempt to uh reach out to
hispanic voters
uh which failed so magnificently was
when um
the dnc in a bunch of other places were
running ads uh describing
trump negatively as uh a cardio
a strong man okay now it can
you know it includes the idea that he is
and untowards
strong man that he is uh partially you
know criminal or corrupt but he's also
a strong man who gets things done and
they started they like ran a bunch of
ads about this and then they stopped it
after a piece in the washington post
some op-ed from some reporter who was
like why are you guys doing this
because lots of people like cardio they
like the guy
the strong man in the community who can
get things done
so we got uh we got one from mk90 tier
one
asset says sourpatch lids i'm a marine
stationed in japan
would be my date for the marine corps
ball 2021
i'm not i can't assume there was a would
you be but the u isn't there so
i'll just have to leave it to you to
message mk 90.
i appreciate the offer thanks for
thinking of me so let me give you some
data about blockchain voting this is
something we've talked about wait wait
before we do okay
uh we got we have a super chat that what
just happened to just wait i just got a
chat
oh okay there it is right
june seth says blockchain voting makes
absolutely no sense i was the host of a
very popular bitcoin podcast i know
quite a bit about the tech
you have to be a complete nutter to
pursue blockchain voting anyway you were
saying
okay so let me pursue blockchain voting
for a moment
um this was sent to me from
someone on mine's name chris in iowa and
it's a
pretty interesting explanation of how we
could use blockchain with our voting
system and keep it legit
uh reads as follows a printing time on
each ballot
uh blockchain's created and burned into
the ballot this would uniquely identify
the individual ballot who printed it and
who authorized his printing
at the voting precinct when a voter
arrives to vote the election worker
places the ballot into a burner again
which burns another entry into the
blockchain this time identifying the
precinct
where it was issued and the worker that
issued it the voter completes the ballot
and then takes it to a third station
where it's scanned and the voter has a
chance to review the conclusions on the
scan
if they dispute the ballot they can take
it back to the workers who burn to spoil
who then burn a spoiled ballot entry
into the blockchain
if they accept it the scan of the ballot
then they insert their driver's license
or voting id
which needs to have its own anonymous
private key
a final blockchain entry is burned in
using the tabulating machine's identity
the voters anonymous public key and the
results
that the tabulating uh okay so at the
final blockchain entries burned in using
the tabulating machine's identity
the voters anonymous public key and the
results that the tabulating machine came
to
let me stop you right let me finish it
because it's almost done well but this
is really esoteric
it's gonna be hard the paper we'll just
just so it's logged we can watch it
listen to it again if you have questions
and you want to listen to it again
the paper ballot is then stored as
normal so there's three blockchain
things that will be marked um the
ballots are still mostly anonymous but
the entire history of the ballot
creation issuancing scan
is burned into the ballot so what you're
saying is you want
in-person paper ballots with voter id
laws
yeah with a blockchain great let's do
hard paper ballots that must be done
in person and you got to present your id
and not only present you got to scan it
into a machine
that verifies on the blockchain i am
down that is blockchain voting that
sounds good wonderful
i agree right you agree as long as as
long as
we can actually still i mean there's
still districts where we haven't
finished counts
i know california and new york i mean
it's it's just
it's embarrassing yeah you know i mean
come on are we the leaders of the free
world or not
no we're not we're not china is by the
way because they're totalitarian
muscling the global economy i mean we
you saw him share this story the other
day nike coca-cola and apple
lobbying against this bill that uh you
know bans products produced with slave
labor
from china fascinating in the new york
times yeah by the way
i want the united states to be the
leaders of the world sorry to interrupt
well that's
it's it's good could be it's we got our
heads
[Laughter]
you know there's just there's i think
our politicians
i think we have no leaders you can
probably count on one hand the
politicians we have in washington who
are actual leaders
i think i think you're right about that
but i also think there's an additional
problem which is that we have
incentivized politicians
to become basically hype men for their
side of the party
they're influencers they're influencers
that's it aoc is the perfect example of
this exactly and it's not about actually
getting anything done
and i think unfortunately we have
reached a point in politics where
anybody who actually is a leader
in their community a significant person
in their in their neighborhood
the kind of people who used to be able
to rise up through the ranks
we've totally incentivized it by
destroying everybody's family
you know tearing them up engaged in the
worst kind
of uh identity and
personal destruction that i think we've
seen in our history
and you know look you can you can
compare it back to
uh you know the founders being nasty to
each other in newspapers
but it really doesn't compare to the
level of
just animus and destruction that can be
directed to people today it's it's
i wouldn't say uh i would i would
absolutely say
what we are experiencing with this is
not trump's fault trump is a symptom
of whatever this is not the cause of it
but i do believe the future of politics
is going to be
you can actually just see it by going to
ocasio-cortez's twitter account
it's clapbacks it's it's it's
meaningless
mindless 280 character clapbacks with
it's you know pelosi tearing up the
speech exactly
so but that's that's kind of an analog
old school
which generally she's she's she's 80 now
isn't she so so what generates is silent
generation
oh my gosh but it's going to be like
this you know aoc
did you see the things she did with the
painting where it was like the green new
deal future
and she was like and the kids were all
excited about being in congress that's
not what it's going to be like
it's going to be like exactly what
you're doing with your silly tweets
where you're like a republican came in
today and i was like bro i
beat you on among us you ain't got
nothing you were the imposter
dude you beat me you're talking about i
had 400 000 concurrents and people going
to vote for it
they're going to be like i'm voting for
aoc because she won it's going to
whittle down
you know what's funny is that it's
almost like idiocracy but what idiocracy
didn't get right with social media
so mike judge was so has been ahead of
the curve every single point
you know that in in idiocracy camacho
was a you know wrestler right yes
trump's in the wwe hall of fame yeah we
we're there baby
and it's going to be just literal social
media live streams and clapbacks no
policy
nothing will make sense they'll pass
bills that are meaningless it's the
green new deal to help the environment
but it's loaded with critical race
theory socialist policy it doesn't have
to be like that though
that's what doesn't have to be but
that's where people listen man look
look at how people have formed echo
chambers on social media
how it's remarkable how people
don't know things in in you know and i
gotta say it's predominantly
a a a a failure of the left because
the right notes the left is thinking the
left doesn't know what the right is
thinking yeah
but man it's like i'll tell you i'll
tell you a funny thing happened
stick sex and hammer he's he's a great
youtuber you're familiar with sticks
yeah a libertarian
man he he he uh made a meme it was
really funny and it was like
uh he makes these paint brush memes that
are funny and it's a guy who's got a
sickle and hammer or something he says
i'm just a a so a social democrat not a
socialist but hey
you check out this really great books
you know karl marx and stuff and
communism is great and all that
so another youtuber tweeted so true in a
bunch of exclamation points
and i responded with so you admit it
clearly
a joke to any reasonable thinking human
being
i don't really think her snarky
responses sticks was literally
literally her being like i'm a communist
but all of the responses from these
lefty f
like you know lefty socialist types were
like i can't believe it you really think
she's confessing oh my god
these people have like limited ability
to think critically no tone
in text it's not just that but it's like
there were a few people were like guys
please stop he's clearly not serious
that's like it's a meme it's everyone's
joking having a good time no
the point is when you make a joke that
it's that dry too much texture
but listen listen it's not it's not so
much to say that they were all dumb
but that they wanted the snapback fight
they wanted the political issue to be
like
oh yeah well we're going to come at you
because my side versus your side when i
was literally just making
a snarky joke braille when i make
youtube videos like 2007 i was like dude
text might is going to be our downfall
as humanity if we keep texting each
other people leaving these text comments
dude speak to me with your voice use
your use your intonation so i can
understand you
and that's where we're at we're at
people with these text storms and you're
creating your own
tone on what they wrote and so there's
all this miscommunication
yeah so so i i said this a while ago
like
i might you got to learn from michael
malus man yeah you know you know you
know
he's a guy's a genius he just kind of
rolls with it and he
he tweets things and when people clearly
don't get it he just goes with it
it's hilarious so i just tweet stuff and
i just don't care anymore
you know these people look it's better
when you don't care
i have to actually put disclaimer this
is a joke on some tweets
and there was one i tweeted about the
election it was on on november 3rd
at like midnight we got these two you
know districts of like
10 and 20 people and they they went for
like together they were for trump by
like six votes but that was you know the
majority
and so i tweeted that's it i'm
projecting trump to be the winner with
0.0000013
reporting we can now you know calmly
project trump is the winner
congratulations okay antifa you can
start rioting now
and people were like whoa dude dude like
you you're gonna get banned and i'm like
come on like that was such a ridiculous
tweet
you actually think i didn't get banned
or anything for it hope
i guess the people at twitter the
moderators were like okay
that one's abs like ridiculous enough
for us to recognize he's not seriously
but the rule was that if you called the
election before it was done
so like the moment we got any results i
was like oh i'm gonna tweet this out it
was funny the
the future i think of of congress and
political leadership
does look very bleak at the moment um
but one thing that i will say that i'm
hopeful about is
we're reaching the point where the the
octogenarians and the septuaginarians
have to leave the room
septuagenarians and that to me is
is a good sign just because i think you
know the degree to which
people who are let's just say under 50
have more of a role
at this point some of those younger gen
xers some of the older millennials start
uh being in the committee rooms and
not no being able to see through like
big tech's bs
without having to have it explained to
them by a much younger aide i think that
does
uh have the potential to make a
difference but we got to get beyond this
moment where
they're just meme makers and hype men do
you got it we have limits
we got to do more super chats yeah
congressional term limits so i i
am opposed to them because i think
people should kind of have to
be able to uh uh you know move people
out but i do think that they
that we actually should consider age
limits maybe
for some for some of our offices and
also the opposite
and i and i think that the problem too
with
with term limits is i would like to see
them more as a uh
enacted within the body so one of the
differences between one of the reasons
the democratic party
uh representation of the house is so
much older than the republicans
is that republicans several years ago
adopted term limits for how long you
could be the chairman of a committee
interesting so what that did was if you
are about to age out and you're no
longer going to be the chairman of a
committee
why were you why would you stick around
and like be just one of the other
members
and so lots of the older members retired
the difference with the democrats is
they never got rid of that
and so you have all these older people
who are the chairman of committees
you know people like jerry nadler still
hanging around you know when they really
ought to have been replaced by and it's
why frankly they
had a bunch of people who are like in
their 40s and 50s leave to go run for
senate or run for governor over the past
several years right on we got
78.26 says hi tim could your band please
do a cover version of the song lydia
purple by the collectors or
lydia by marty ballen i bet that it
would be awesome
all right great suggestions i like those
jeffrey paris says
this new trans issue is like the concept
of ancient roman adoption
julius caesar adopted octavian the law
stated that once adopted you were a new
entity entirely
anyone who referenced your old identity
could be arrested and executed
wow history repeats itself crazy
let's see we got here william shellman
says hey tim i live in germantown
wisconsin and there is a protest outside
the house of the wauwatosa
police chief there are no reporters at
all it's some sort of bla
blm thing over a shooting from last year
wow wow really interesting
andrew land says dude thanks for cutting
back on content
between you crowder shapiro and michael
knowles i had no time to get anything
done p.s
get michael knowles on to explain
conservatism he has a really good take
on it well for those that are curious
you can arguably say in some capacity
i'm cutting down but i'm actually doing
this to try and
increase the amount i can produce so for
those that aren't familiar
today i announced that i'm going to be
doing less segments on my individual
channel focusing more on segments on irl
so actually what we're basically going
to do is we're going to have
news stories that i would normally cover
we'll just do on this show with a guest
so it'll be interesting to get their
take on a lot of these issues which we
kind of did here with ben
but uh the reason why i'm doing that is
not because i'm going to be doing less
it's because we're going to be launching
a new channel
the way i described it is at a certain
point doing segments where you talk
about what's going
on and complain about it and say it's a
problem doesn't
do enough to solve any of these issues
and what needs to happen is there needs
to be cultural development
if all we're gonna get is you know aoc
she did among us that stream got 400
000 concurrent viewers so all the people
who watch her are constantly being
inundated with
leftists they're watching these you know
bread tube types and these socialists
and these younger people are are hearing
that and they're developing with these
ideas
if you want your political ideas to
persist then you need to be engaging
young people and things that they find
entertaining as well
so sitting around complaining will get
you nowhere in the future
so the way i described it is there's a
there's a skateboarder that's really
good who's got the gad
he's got a mini ramp it's a half pipe
and there's the gadsden flag painted in
the middle of it
when kids watch that they see the
gadsden flag they might not know what it
is
but they might hear their teacher say
that's a white supremacist symbol and
they're going to go what
no way dude's got that on his ramp
you're crazy it's going to give them
some pushback it's going to show them
there's other things and these people
aren't telling them the truth
long story short we're going to do a
vlog we're going to do fun things we're
going to you know do science experiments
skateboarding
we're going to do like the world's
longest grind rail mega jumps and just
have a good time and have fun
but it's also going to incorporate to a
certain degree some of the guests we
bring on the show to give a more like
culture role less political and just
doing fun things
tournaments yes passively you know board
games
we just played we just played as a board
game called conspiracy
theory it was awesome and it's a trivia
game and i
dominate no totally well uh
andreas won the first one and then i won
the second one but it was it was
was it when did you guys play was it
last night two
so one of the questions was um it was uh
what what
uh what monster is associated with
silver bridge in west virginia
and i was like i know it mothman because
they just watched the movie
well i've all i've known about mother he
knows conspiracy i know weird and i was
like
i was like this is amazing i know so
much bs that would be a fun game to
stream but it would be really fun to get
like alex jones
and like one of the questions he was in
the game he's gonna answer
all of them but wouldn't it be really
funny to have a video that's not
political
not talking about any of this dumb stuff
it's literally like alex jones can you
answer these conspiracy theory trivia
questions
it's like hot ones just silly fun that
is that is
a great combination of things there you
know i mean
and honestly like there there could be a
stump him kind of
contest there basically he's going to
answer all of them i know it yeah
no jokes we'll shoot a bunch and then
just release them once no
one a week just to keep everybody i love
conspiracy but that's just like an idea
i'm not saying it's
literally something we'll like i would
like to do it we'll see what happens
there's funny ideas like that we could
do we have a lot of people who come in
and out of this place and it's it would
be fun to do silly things
look it's it's simple you gotta you
gotta make the culture because politics
is downstream yeah you've got to inspire
young people to get access that's
something you were talking about
less reliant on the leader politicians
and more reliant on like what did you
create what did you do today what
you have you done i don't think that
politicians have
the narrative power they once did and i
think that there are a lot of other
entities that have a lot more narrative
power and different avenues to it
and as we're seeing that change it
requires a lot more engagement
from the creative folks who may have
wanted to stay away from
politicizing anything they're doing but
recognizing how much it's taking over
everything
i think we have to step forward and see
those folks really get an opportunity
to tell the stories they want to they
want to tell that are fascinating and
amazing often and
inform us in so many different ways
there's so many people who came to their
views about politics from
reading science fiction you know and and
reading you know heinlein and things
like that and taking away
different aspects of it i think right
now we have to recognize that that's
way more important than you know who's
in charge of of different entities when
it comes to federal government we're
going to be doing events
we're going to be doing frequent events
i don't know how with covid lockdown's
getting more and more strict we'll see
how things play out
but we're going to do events we've got a
uh this cool clubhouse thing we're
building it's a skate park
we're gonna we're we're doing
construction in the back and we're gonna
start a brand and we're gonna sell merch
and very much so the idea
is to be fun family friendly
but very individualist healthy masculine
you know i don't i don't want to say
conservative i just want to be like
you know self-reliant kind of promote
these ideas healthy feminine
absolutely absolutely healthy feminine
all these things that are kind of
getting washed away because we have this
very
unhealthy mainstream celebrity apparatus
where they only go in one direction
there's got to be someone who's going to
be like nah
look i'll put it this way i know a bunch
of pro skateboarders
skateboarders are supposed to be the
anti-authoritarian lefty you know
renegades
many of them are pro-trump they're
hitting me up saying like i want to send
you a bunch of free stuff
i love your content man i hope trump
wins and i'm like why aren't you
telling people that in your skate videos
why aren't you like when you when you do
not skateboard but like their vlogs when
they're posting things on instagram why
aren't you saying like here's what i
think
well i don't want to lose my sponsors
okay well i don't care because this is
who i am i talk about stuff all the time
great
i'll make the skate videos i'll put the
gadsden flag in my skate park
and i'll make a video where you can see
it every single time someone does a
trick is that the don't tread on me yes
that's a snake and it's literally like
something it's if you want to talk about
opposing fascism
and opposing authoritarianism and
tyranny that's what that flag don't
shred on me
exactly and that's circling back to what
you were saying before about the
cultural differences when it comes to
guns
the number one thing that people need to
understand is that you know
the second amendment it's not about
hunting it's about the relationship
between the citizen and the state
but it's it's it's i think the founding
fathers were a little bit even
more broad than that yeah it wasn't just
the citizens of the state it was
the citizens and uh with the state and
the data
americans exactly exactly there were
instances where when
like in the revolutionary would you ever
see the movie the patriot with mel
gibson of course
amazing but militia was forming this the
famous thing was in the end they're like
militia was forming the center
they we in the revolutionary war we
needed much so over the top
gifts the movies are if you think about
well the founding fathers were like
in the revolutionary war we needed as
many armed and capable individuals to
fight for us which means
you need an armed citizenry to defend
the state yeah not just from itself
because they were fighting you know
people don't realize you know they say
uh you know paul revere's ride the
british are coming he didn't say the
british are coming
they were british he said the regulars
are coming why would you be like the
americans are coming in like the cops
are coming
you know run or whatever the uh have you
seen apocalypto
yeah i
i think that i just think that film is
amazing
uh i thought it was great and and uh but
it also
it goes to that idea the little village
that is this kind of bucolic you know
sleepy community that suddenly is
crushed
by you know the invader and it's a
totally big city for it exactly
and there's so many elements of that
that i think you can take into
the you know about the relationships
that citizens ought to have in in
solving
their own problems and being prepared to
defend the town to defend
what they value most um and that that's
essential
you ever hear of what's called the
battle of athens i think is this this
one's like
no no no no no this is uh the military
events this is the military veteran oh i
have heard of this this is
fascinating come back from world war ii
to find a political machine
controlling everything and so they took
their guns and they went they were like
nah
and they took over and made sure the
votes were cast with the votes that were
the votes were all counted properly and
ensured the election was done properly
yep there was a corrupt political
machine controlling the town and they
were like
nope crazy this crazy crazy place we
live in this america where people are
like nah
you know what so we have a little thing
uh just to
do a little self-promotion that the the
1620 project at the federalist
has been running essays for 16 20
projects yes and it is not designed to
refound america the founding of america
is 1776 but
in 1620 obviously 400 years ago the
arrival of the pilgrims uh in
in america the 400 year anniversary of
both the mayflower compact uh
last month and in uh uh three weeks uh
from uh today it'll be the
400th anniversary of plymouth rock and
wow and
what is so fascinating is you know this
is a group of people who embody in so
many ways the things that were essential
to
the crazy country that is america
they're they're religious zealots
who you know have to run away from
england you know they're
outcasts of some kind of their own
community they they
gather together and they raise money and
they have all these you know tragedies
they have no idea what they're getting
into they get on this boat they come
across
the ocean uh you know within uh within
through the winter they lose like half
of the people they're totally unprepared
for this
and yet they end up making a firm enough
uh ground on on that area that we still
have people today
there there are hundreds and hundreds of
thousands of people even millions
uh some claim who are descended directly
from the people who came over on that
boat
and that's you have to have this
combination of like courage
and commitment and crazy yeah
i'm gonna go on a boat for three months
where people are gonna die on the way
there the martian these are the martian
colonists man it's
gonna be another generation you know you
know what's really crazy a lot of people
really gotta learn american history we
went through i think several presidents
before we actually got a constitution
so we had the articles of confederation
for a long time and the states didn't
cooperate didn't pay taxes
there was constant bickering and
fighting and when they passed the
constitution i was reading about this
just recently
they just they decided we're going to do
a two-thirds ratification
if the states that you know these other
states that don't approve of this they
don't have to abide by it but once they
do
we got it we're done and that was
basically how they were able to get
a constitution when the states didn't
work with each other the federalist
papers
were making the case for that
constitution yeah
you know uh and designed to be able to
convince people that this was the right
but it was the anti-federalists that got
the bill of rights yes
they were like we don't trust you
hamilton hamilton didn't want a bill of
rights he
he thought it was unnecessary he also
thought it would restrict uh government
too much and the arguments of the
anti-federalists including patrick henry
uh were convincing enough to the people
that no we need to put some things in
place
that actually restrain government from
invading all these
areas of life and boy were they right
yeah man not a day goes by
the constitution is is shielding us and
people don't realize we we have to
seriously
it you know when people swear an oath to
the constitution it's just a piece of
paper they say but it is
it is a it is a piece of paper that is a
gigantic golden mithril shield
protecting us from so much evil and
tyranny
these people who want to lock down
everything in the defiance of science
while they go out and party they're
they're getting away with it in many
circumstances
and it's only after the fact after the
courts that the the supreme court says
well the constitution
but you look at countries in europe you
look at what's going on with the eu
and there's riots because they're like
stay in your home you can't leave no
matter what
the cops they swear an oath to nothing
the cops are like i don't care the state
says you get arrested
you see that video of the woman in spain
getting tased because she brought her
grandma whatever to the hospital for
mental illness they taser because they
have no oath to anything but but
themselves in their job
here you have a constitution to contend
with and people who believe in it
yeah it's not it's not it's not a
perfect shield because they can go
around it and try
and they can violate the constitution
but like you were saying earlier a lot
of these
rule changes to the elections a lot of
things they've done will be found to be
unconstitutional absolutely i love that
piece of paper huh let's read some more
super chats
because we're going we're going a little
late on this one jacob bailey says
only 19 bellwether counties have been
100 accurate and choosing the president
since 1980.
donald trump donald trump won 18 of
those 19 counties in 2020
plus the three bellwether states which
is iowa ohio and florida trump won those
as well
a lot of people hard to believe biden
won with all of these things there was a
really good comment i saw i remember was
it from they said
if there was no widespread voter fraud
shifting the results and costing trump
the election then why is it that
all of the discrepancies hurt donald
trump and help joe biden
well i don't think that we can
necessarily say that that's true just
because
the campaign is not looking for
discrepancies that help donald trump
um but i will say that there are a lot
of
weird a historical elements to this
the recounts in georgia the we've never
seen a recount margin that large
it was and it was just i mean again the
people who just say
you can't question this those are the
ones who just discussed me because it's
just so ridiculous the stuff that matt
brainer's been uncovering is like well i
don't know again i don't know i don't
know if any of that is is provable but
what i will say is
questioning the the idea that it's
destroying democracy
to say hey some weird stuff happened
here we should probably look into it
it's absurd that's protecting democracy
it's the opposite of what you're talking
about here that's making sure that you
know
every vote counts every vote is equal my
vote for
you know uh zaphod biebel brock's is it
just as valuable
as a vote for joe biden yeah and it
deserves to be counted
like it's like when you're playing a
game with your friend and something
happens
and you're like oh i lost and then you
give them the win if they didn't see
that you lost but you still tell them i
lost
you won maybe it's just because it's not
a game to these people we got it we got
a good one archimedes says tim if you
think the battle of athens is good
why are you weary of trump possibly
doing the same ensuring the votes are
done correctly
there's a big difference between trump
declaring martial law
and then holding a new election that's
what people are calling for the the the
what what they're saying here is we need
a new clean federal election
that's going to be civil war like they
they say to
this guy put out this ad saying to avoid
civil war declare martial law i'm like
no that would that would be
literally trump igniting civil war the
battle of athens was a small town
the problem is and the difficulty is
scale but i will say
i want trump to fight tooth and nail to
the bitter end and i want a clean
investigation i want everything to be
gone you know they want i want to go
through the fine-tooth
comb and figure out if there was we know
that there is evidence of fraud
we know according to matt brainer there
is evidence of widespread fraud
i'm not saying definitive proof i'm
saying evidence signs are indications
that a thing occurred
that needs to be investigated it
absolutely has to be
now i don't know what trump can do and i
don't i don't think martial law
and declaring a new election is the
right thing to do because that would
just
be civil war but this i was going to
bring this up before let me ask you
if it's true that some group
cheated and all of these widespread
anomalies
actually are widespread voter fraud to
steal the election from the american
people
should then trump stop it by declaring
martial law i just think that we're
we would be in an unprecedented
situation if that was something that was
provable but how would you
right how would you know i don't know i
don't think that see that's the problem
i don't know that we have an entity set
up to find that out and i think that
we've discovered an aspect of our voting
process
well so that leaves us vulnerable to
that service so hypothetically
evidence dropped or you saw evidence you
knew for a fact
that widespread voter fraud a
centralized plan
a group behind it was going to steal the
election and most people don't care
because they support biden
what do you think trump should declare i
don't think that martial law is the way
to go there only because i think it will
set fire to tinder and turn into a civil
war but i do think but i do think there
would be
other guard rails that would come into a
place there
that would have to adjudicate this if if
something like that came out the supreme
court would you would have a route
to basically going before them and i
think additionally
you would have a situation where in a
very closely divided congress
there are a number of things that they
could do including in the senate
i think calling for a federal based
look at recounts within the system which
is actually something that has happened
before
albeit in a senate context like senate
looking at senate races where they
actually
sent the ballots to washington to have a
full recount there because they didn't
trust the state officials they've
already destroyed envelopes though
and so the so the issue the problem is
the the problem is that the ballots are
in there already
you you the place to stop this the place
to stop this was before they got in
there
because once they get in there they're
so hard to remove but when they tried to
sue
they said no injury in fact nothing's
happened yet you can't sue there's
nothing no harm has done it on anybody
you wait till that so here's what
happens with uh sean
hold on no yes that's how it works so so
with uh sean parnell and and you know he
has this lawsuit
about the constitutionality of mail in
voting if he
many people are saying if they would
have voted beforehand then the courts
would have said there's no injury in
fact i mean
there's no hope no harm has come to you
you have no grounds to bring this loss
you have no standing
because they wait until afterwards they
say you're too late you should have you
should have sued sooner
now in sean's john parnell since he said
i didn't know we all assumed that this
law was constitutional
and then it was only now that we're just
finding out they they were going to
actually try to amend the constitution
and stopped meaning
that in my here this is my opinion i
think they knew it was unconstitutional
and they said stop trying to amend the
constitution just ram it through
so here we are now with people suing
saying hey wait a minute and the supreme
court of pennsylvania
shot it down not on its merits because
it was too late meaning
it's very likely unconstitutional this
that means what do you think what do you
think is going to happen
if joe biden and he wins partly because
of pennsylvania in a month from now they
say oh yeah by the way pennsylvania's
election
yeah job yeah it was all
unconstitutional should not have been
allowed at all
do you think trump support is going to
be like rats we'll try better next time
or do you think they're going to be like
screaming and angry and demanding you
know something be done
judges are politicians too yeah they
absolutely are
trump still has twitter that's a thing
trump's got four years that he can just
command
people to go do something yeah and they
will sauron says
once the electors choose biden it won't
matter if the votes of the people were
fraudulent unfortunately
legally he would be president once the
electors cast their belts incorrect good
sir
that is not true he's not president
until he's inaugurated he'll be he would
be president-elect
after january 6th when congress holds a
joint session to count the electoral
votes
at which point anybody can raise
objections by the way have you
did you go back uh ever and look at the
objections that were raised after
last time around when the democrats
tried to pull out they were nuts
they were absolutely insane and biden
was actually in you're he's in the chair
just like pence will be this time um to
to adjudicate these
and he had you know a script that he was
reading off this time around i wonder if
we're going to see the flip side of that
with
oh definitely and then we we now have
the durham probe special counsel
and i think we're going to see the
democrats go through oh
totally and and they're gonna and
they're gonna try but they will try to
defund him cut him off i wonder frankly
if if
they will try to convince uh biden to
appoint someone uh to the to the ag
role who will actually fire him perhaps
because that could be
interesting itself well my friends we
went uh went a little bit long just
trying to get as many super chats as
possible but thank you all so much for
hanging out make sure you smash
that like button subscribe we're live
monday through friday at 8 8pm
and uh we're going to be booking more
and more guests we're going to be doing
more on the show and we're also got uh
going to be building out this vlog
channel we got construction happening so
stick around
more content to come it's a little bit
different we're going to be expanding
the business
going to be hiring more people going to
be doing journalism could be doing all
this good stuff
going to be blowing stuff up and
electrocuting things and i don't even
know we're going to do some crazy stuff
and have a good time
but stick around for that we'll be back
tomorrow live at 8 pm you can follow me
on twitter instagram parlor at tim cast
check out my other youtube channels
youtube.comtimcast
and youtube.comtimcastnews ben you want
to give a shout out to anything
uh just you can follow me on twitter at
bedominitch and uh
i hope you'll check out the 1620 project
we have a really cool
pilgrim shirt that you should check out
in our store
right on that's on your website
thefederlist.com yes all right
uh yeah thanks tim thanks ben lydia i'm
ian crossland you guys can follow me ian
crossland smash the
like button and share yeah share the
video
man i think sharing is really uh sharing
is a powerful tool sharing is caring
you can also get a friend out there that
wants that's going to be really happy
right on when they find out you can also
follow thanks for watching it's lyds i
do think that sharing is caring and i do
like that our show starts a lot of
conversations
i think that's right yeah and maybe
we'll get banned yeah eventually yeah
all right everybody thanks for hanging
out ben thanks for hanging out and we
will see you guys tomorrow
at 8 p.m live on this channel right bye
guys
you